[Music]
it's here
the final of the magnus calls an
invitational with
anish giri and jana pomnyacci playing
the chess
of their life but who will be the winner
we hope you're ready for some drama
welcome to the final of the magnus
carlson invitational
grand master great commander
magnus carlsen will be angry he was
knocked out in the semi-finals yesterday
this is the second major in the meltdown
champions chest for
the winner one of these two will take
home 60 thousand dollars
and qualify directly for the tour final
now to take us through this final
women's grandmaster van kylska
and grandmaster david howell and david
is allowed to say that we are a little
bit surprised
with the two finalists yeah i don't
think anyone any of the fans at home
could have predicted
this matchup in the final especially
yana pontiacci maybe having overcome the
world champion yesterday in dramatic
circumstances yeah but these two players
yeah anish geary and jana prominently
they truly are playing the chess of
their lives
yeah absolutely and i think the main
reason is because
both are in serious training for the
candidates match the
tournament that is going to happen at
the end of
april and of course they are in form
they are sharp and they are also in
fighting mood
i can see that uh the twitter war
has begun
first with his tweet that was always two
that are
no more no less a master and an
apprentice
and of course he is quoting his beloved
yoda and who is the master
well probably actually think this isn't
there is only one
yeah well uh he maybe thinks he is the
favorite than being the monster but
uh who does the world think is the
favorite among these two well
it's bad news for you actually because
chess 24 conducted a poll
on their instagram and the followers of
chester new 4 decided that anish
giri is the big favorite 68
of followers voted for him and also they
believe that magnus carlsen
would defeat wesley so in the battle for
third place
all right that's also today we do have a
very
very cool day of chess ahead of us let's
take a look at
the schedule there will be four
games in the final first match
and uh well if we have uh
someone on two and a half points after
three it's going to be finished after
three but this is only the first match
in the final we know there's two matches
also one tomorrow and uh we're also
gonna have something really really
exciting for you today the magnus
carlsen celebrity charity chess
challenge with the second celebrity mr
kuba
gooding jr that's going to be so much
fun and we will also
later be joined by ginger gm
but obviously it is all about the final
today but it is
the magnus calls an invitational so we
are talking a lot about
magnus calls now uh the next chapter in
the story about him will be
after the first game he started playing
chess when he was only four years old
became a grandmaster at 13 and at 22
he became the 16th chess world champion
this was a larger than life experience
you have this
exotic feel the smells the noise
it's so overwhelming and together with
hundreds of journalists it was such an
uh mesmerizing experience
a team of grandmasters knows everything
about magna skulls
and they're off
[Music]
i think i said after the match that well
now i can die
all right so we're going to have more
about this intriguing story after the
first game magnus cross night it's the
magnus carlsen invitational so
david do you think it's specifically
hard for him to be knocked out in the
semi-finals in this one
yeah he would have found it
heartbreaking he was very disappointed
in his interview yesterday
um because he knows it was a it was a
story of miss chances in that semi-final
he had the opportunities
he could be here today in the final
instead he's playing for third place and
he's got to pick himself up and find
that motivation to beat wesley so
who's been such a difficult opponent for
him in the past yeah
so not playing the chess of his life in
this tournament uh magnus carlsen he was
playing fantastic chess
in this uh 2013 world championship match
and it is about great chess games in the
quiz of the day of ankara
yeah absolutely and we are asking
everyone in the in our question of the
day
what is your favorite chess game
and uh the prize well this
is a bumper bumper prize and it's been
brought to us
by a opera and the free will get this
car
i have to hold on to the edge of my seat
because this is super exciting
the winner wins a niche geary sicilian
night off chesapore course
one year chessable pro membership if
that's not enough
one year chess 24 premium membership and
then
one year magnus trainer membership i
mean that's
absolutely and then in one minute you're
going to participate in the
meltwater championship basically exactly
i mean you're just going to have a
wealth of knowledge at your fingertips
and yeah you can tweet your answer using
the hashtag chesschamps and if you can
send us your pictures we absolutely love
to see them
all right well do join in that's going
to be so much fun to hear
your stories and and what chess games
you really like today
um let's take a look back at what
happened yesterday magnus carlsen he
lost the first match in the semi-finals
against janna pognachi
but on day two he was able to make an
insane
comeback wow okay
i'm speechless white's last move giving
up a pawn he's
i mean he's just giving away his extra
point it was a tense
semi-final match between magnus carson
and jana pomniacci
in game two it dawned on the world
champion that he might
not be in the finals of his own
invitational tournament
personally i think i would struggle to
find that winning move now no i mean the
first move that you're thinking about
is the the checks you're looking at the
captures
wow showing great form after one draw
and one loss
magnus fought back from the brink
winning games three and four
fifteen seconds for yon pumnachi to find
this move
and it's not found out wow napoli
actually made a move with one second
left
look black's about to make a new queen
but queen for only a rook and a pawn and
the key thing is black has enough pawns
left to win
30 seconds left there we go napoleon
resigns
magnus all of his previous play was
justified
white's rook at the bottom of the board
is just going to bring itself up align
itself with the other rook and that's
game over the black bishop will fall
the pomniacci he's about to resign i
think there we go wow
chief just gives up wow wow wow
wow magnus calls in a must win situation
with two games to go
and he wins both of those games
in the tie breaks the speedy russian won
his spot in the finals to meet aneesh
giri
slipped again he's lost his queen and
wins
what is your feelings right now after
winning this in tie breaks
clearly today it was a lottery and i was
the one to
who got the winning ticket when one
player has nothing to lose and
another player has everything to lose
yeah normally a miracle comes here yeah
yeah i was obviously happy to get to get
to the blitz but i i still had
sort of a iffy feeling
because i knew that the job was far far
from from
dawn congrats to jan and
wishing best of luck in the finals
and here we are have it after quarter
finals
and then semi-finals magnus carlsen
losing the second blitz game
and jana pomnyacci being the winner of
the semi-final match and the other one
anish geary was able to win both
of the matches and he knocked out wesley
so
and here we have it the final will be
between jan
pomnyachi and anish giri it's the first
time both of these
are in a mel torture champions chess
tour final
and david how will it be decided the
final will be decided over
two days a best of four game match on
each day
if after these two days we see the sides
on
one match a piece then we will head to
tie breaks
blitz and armageddon chess where time
will be slashed
the final though it starts with rapid
all right so in a form like this i i
have to ask you right away who is the
favorite who do you hold as favorite
yoanka
i have to say between the two i think
it's been anish giri that's
really impressed me you know he was
absolutely blistering in the
preliminaries
and he just really taken all his
opponents apart and i was super
impressed with what he did to wesley so
and you have to remember wesley
has won two tour events in the past so
i'm absolutely impressed he's never got
as far as this and
yeah i think anisha's favorite for me
but janna pognati we named him the
russian bear
yesterday david knocking out magnus
carlsen it seems
nothing affects him yeah the russian
bear the speed demon uh we saw it in his
interviews he wasn't satisfied with just
beating magnus carlsen
he wants more and he holds himself to
such high standards
i wouldn't be surprised if he does get
his way past anishigiri he's also very
experienced we shouldn't forget the
ponyachi he is capable
but he has to get back past anish geary
who is
playing uh the best chess of his entire
life
and playing great chess he now has to
answer a question that he really doesn't
like to answer
what will it actually mean to win this
tournament
i should probably care about tournament
victories because people
around me seem to care about yeah that's
true that's that's why
because i mean honestly i yes as i told
you i
it's how it is i mean i'm happy i'm
unhappy with this uh
last game but uh uh happy with many
things and
and just uh my you know my process
it just never stops you know every day i
wake up i turn on my chest software
i look at um at new ideas you know i
prepare then i play tournament then i go
back
again and like it's like you know it's
continuous thing and whatever
happens just the you know the machine
will keep on moving so i
for me it doesn't affect anything
actually but yeah i mean
people around me will be probably
happier uh if i win
and then yeah let's let's obviously i
mean
the whole purpose of course is to win
yeah that's obviously the whole goal of
everything
but i mean that yeah some things are um
uh
under your control and some are outside
but i i think i will have a good shot
i'm curious
very curious who will who uh it will be
i mean it's one thing to play young
oh it's great of course but it's uh
another story if you play magnus so
we'll see about that
and uh this was before and each gear we
could see anapogniacci being the winner
of that semi-final and it is now
these two players up against each other
aneesh geary sitting in the netherlands
it's five o'clock for him when the final
starts for yana pomnyacci
a little bit later in moscow it's gonna
be seven o'clock for him
in the evening when the final starts and
uh listening to anishigiri here david
is that the fact that he's not that used
to winning tournaments
yeah actually maybe the one criticism of
anish giri's whole career is that he has
struggled on that final step
of winning tournaments magnus carlsen
has teased him about it in the in the
past before andi
he's always there all thereabouts but
when the chips are down he does
fall at that final hurdle um i think
he's come first place
in a super tournament only once and that
was a shared title
um we saw it in tata steel as well in
january he failed he lost in the
armageddon
so he needs to overcome his personal
demons and make that breakthrough yeah
he's going to be hungry for a tournament
victory do you think ivanka
definitely because this is going to set
the mood for that all-important
candidates tournament that is going to
resume at the end of april
and uh if anish wins then okay
he his triumphant he will set him in a
good really good mood
and you also have to remember remember
that in the last candidate tournament
that they played in at the beginning
napomniachi beat so anish will be
looking for
revenge you know it's a very powerful
motivator that
all right but we haven't mentioned it
several times both of these players are
playing the chess of their lives david
we do know yana pomnyachi
his all-time he's on his all-time high
rating that's in classical chess but
what does it look like between these two
in rapid chess yeah in rapid chess as we
see
in front of us anish giri he's only
ranked number 25 in the world slightly
surprising
for such a superstar janna pogniacci
however is ranked number nine in the
world
he does have pedigree he also once came
second in the world rapid championship
so
his results traditionally have been
slightly better than anishigiri's also
with a higher rating there
but they haven't faced each other too
many times in the meltwater champions
chester look at this
yep that's right only four games against
each other only in the preliminary stage
they've never faced each other in the
nitty-gritty in those knockout stages
um so this is going to be a real first
for them and
scores are tied right now with only one
winner piece either side could take it
so close to call but you did mention
ivanka it wasn't the candidates
last year when it was started uh giri
lost to napogniachi yes
and i think um geary he only had one
loss in the preliminaries that's right
tuna pomegranate and that was tuna
pognyachi yeah so is this maybe the
worst possible opponent for geary in
this final quite possibly
um it's it's always i think every chess
player you have that bogey man you have
someone you struggle against
someone is your kryptonite and for gary
he's going to try and prove that it that
isn't nep omni actually
he's going to hope it isn't three times
in a row in three big important games
it's getting close now only seconds
until the first game in the first
match in the final what will the players
and maybe especially anish who's not too
used to being in these final situations
what do you think his nerves will be
like now
i mean i think most players they would
be struggling with nerves but aneesh
whatever he's doing is working for him
we heard it in the past he didn't expect
to win this tournament
he didn't expect to get uh so deep into
it and
uh now being here in the final he's
gonna try and well he's gonna hope that
he can approach it in the same way with
minimum
kind of pressure on himself just playing
freely playing with confidence and
he looks pretty confident right now just
cleaning those glasses getting ready for
the action
and the glasses are on and are you
surprised javanka to see
what shirt jana pognachi is wearing well
no
i mean i i i do hope that you know
once over the board chess resumes that
that this uh
lucky shirt yep thing that the players
are doing can uh wow okay david yeah one
of my favorite openings
um the c3 sicilian um i've been playing
this since birth pretty much
and uh anish giri he's gone for one of
the most popular lines
um so he did start with his king's pawn
earlier on janna probably
counted in his favorite way the most
dynamic way to play against the king's
pawn opening is the sicilian
and anishigiri he's gone into this line
it's
pretty well respected for white it's
maybe not the most critical
uh way the most direct way of trying to
fight against the sicilian but
it does have a decent reputation
personally i've used
this opening myself against for example
gary kasparov in a training match
this putting white's knight on the edge
of the board as well it's not to be
recommended usually but that knight is
destined to jump into
a more active square this position very
well known very popular
and who's the better prepared player who
has done their homework better
anishigiri has played up to this point
instantly i think on the flip side
napoli actually there was no way he
could have predicted that anishigiri
would play into this opening and um
yeah i think i personally haven't seen
any giri do this before
yana pony actually though has he been
prepared has he studied this opening
he's blitzed up to this point but now
napoli actually is spending a bit
a bit of time for the first occasion in
this game
um a bit of tension here black's queen
is also in the middle of the board so
that queen is a target
that is why napoleon is thinking right
now the black queen could
come under fire if napoli actually isn't
careful
and um that's one of the most important
things in chess keeping your queen safe
the probably actually the onus is on him
on how to develop how to get the black
king into safety how to
retreat the black queen when the time
comes just a few questions that napoleon
is taking a bit of time out to answer
now
all right um an ich geary with the white
pieces in this one and that is because
he
uh scored the better of these two in the
preliminary so he will always have that
advantage
of choosing colors if we get to tie
breaks and stuff like that
yep definitely a big a big advantage
if it comes down to tie breaks the
current position white has a huge threat
however
um i think we have to bring up the
analysis board because in this position
white has
okay the black queen retreated white
temporarily sacrificed a piece after
pawn takes pawn
allowing this pawn to capture the bishop
on the next move because white jumped
forward with his knight
creating a threat and a trap if black
gets greedy and takes this bishop
then we see what's known as a family
fork a royal fork here the king is
attacked with check the queen is
attacked and the rook is attacked in the
corner this knight
is going to win the game on its own
that's why napoli actually in this
position he couldn't allow the knight to
penetrate into his camp he had to step
his queen back and cover this square
and now we did see uh this knight no
longer jumping forward
it did jump back and capture a pawn in
the center and that knight has been
traded
this last move i don't think is the most
popular for black
i think in this position the most
often seen move is to bring black's
other knight into the middle of the
board
instead black captured and white now has
a supremely strong bishop in the middle
of the board
this bishop it's hard to get rid of it
look it's aiming both sides it's aiming
towards this side and if the black king
castles on the right side of the board
it's going to be a target so white's
bishop now is incredibly strong i think
anishigiri he's had a successful opening
it's looking good for white ahead in
development as well
now i do see that aneesh with white
pieces is sort of
clearing the way for his king on both
sides
yes only one piece on the queen on this
side and the bishop on this side so what
side should we expect him to castle good
question kaia i mean
you've pretty much nailed the most
important thing that anish giri has to
work out
over the next few moves um i would be
very tempted to castle towards that left
side of the board
because for black there's only one safe
way to castle this one
only one side which has full pawn
protection so black is guaranteed to
castle on the right side
if any she's feeling very ambitious
he'll castle towards the left and throw
all his pawns forward
towards the black king he doesn't need
to do that if he wants to play safer
just kind of with this
long-term stable advantage then he'll
just castle on the same side as black
castle towards that right side the
king's side
and um yeah meanwhile napoli actually
he's going to start realizing that he
did not anticipate this position and
therefore
he has struggled so far and that's why
he's having a thing he just needs to
get that black king to safety that's
priority number one you can fight for
the center later
um look at that white bishop though so
good jamanca i have to say
actually um just checking the database
and checking the statistics
it's heavily in white's favor so it's a
little bit of an odd choice by
napoleonicity to choose an
opening variation like that where the
odds are so balanced
for white um yeah i mean but it's got a
great pedigree actually
vishwanathan anand has played this with
white wesley so
as well wang hao young christophe duda
walla keaton it just goes on but no no
howls on my database
because uh my opponents they normally
choose better variations than this to
fight against the c3 sicilian
um when they're black look at those two
white bishops by the way they are
pointing towards that right side of the
board
it's as as if anishigiri he's daring
black to castle and
he does napoli actually castle castling
into it castling into the danger
wow that's a brave move okay kaya i
think
um yeah i think the question well i
don't know the question that you asked
is still in play okay oh oh he moves his
queen
is annie lining up castling towards the
left side of the board if he does it
would you do that david would you would
you just go queenside
yeah he's very aware of his fans he
knows what the fans are wanting right
now they want to castle
on that queen side and there he doesn't
we have a queen side castle and here
yeah that's so principled
um that's i mean he's going for it right
now um he's going for that win and
look white's king sidesteps once more
but
it's looking great vanish giri okay
david what do you think about this
choice
by niche gear what does it tell us about
his attitude now
i mean he's showing no fear already at
this point we did talk about nerves but
it may be
getting in the way um he hasn't really
won too many super tournaments in the
past but
um yup he's uh blitzed up to this point
it's still 16 minutes on the clock
challenge gary
he is not worrying about anything right
now he's just looking for the best moves
and
okay napoli actually knows that maybe
black is in a bit of trouble
um so he has to launch a counter-attack
before it's too late
uh black pushing a pawn here um if we
bring up the analysis board we can see
napolita's plan with the last move
black just pushing this pawn but the
problem is what next
yes you can push the pawn one square
further for example if white just
centralizes the rook
you push this pawn one square further
but that's as far as you'll go white
will just block it up if you ever push a
pawn forward you just lose a pawn
um it will take black so many moves to
get any pieces to support an attack
black's only playing with one queen on
this side of the board no backup
and meanwhile look at white's pieces the
these are pretty much
the perfect pieces in chess they're all
centralized they all control
so many squares i mean especially these
two bishops i think these guys will do
the dane uh do the dirty work later they
will aim towards that black king
and it looks dominant for white right
now yeah it looks
totally dominant i completely agree with
you that david
the only thing i have is uh how is white
going to continue the attack
because obviously what yeah that's that
is the move i
really wanted you to show and exactly
and if you notice black has actually
pushed one of their pawns on the right
side which we call the king's side
one step forward which means yeah
exactly which means that the
the opening point the point where
white's pawn will come into contact with
the black pawn
is actually a lot less so the square is
can you highlight the square and
uh then we can see that it takes
actually white two moves to get there
yeah white will just push a pawn forward
yeah this one and use this as a hook
to open things up exactly we call that
kind of
a hook just as david said and
it's definitely a very very dangerous
dangerous
idea because if you can imagine a
position where the two bishops are
firing on all cylinders
then you get then we throw in a white
rook and then three is the magic number
and let's not discount the possibilities
of the queen getting into the action so
absolutely uh critical time for
napomniachi i mean how is he going to
stop this
yeah what would you do here is anish
would you push the giri
immediately would you just like forget
about bringing the rook to the center
because maybe
if you push a pawn maybe the rook wants
to be on this line yeah towards the
black king
yeah i mean i wasn't necessarily focused
on the center i was
thinking about moves like okay this one
didn't enter my radar i was actually
thinking of the knight jumping
into the center to support pawn push um
but yeah
wow oh david can you make sense of this
move
i i'm shocked by this last move by
energy to be honest he's going for this
black rook
in the corner and this black rook
attacked napoli actually immediately
moved it
but the problem is what next how do you
get to this black rook meanwhile you do
always allow the opportunity of this
bishop being captured this bishop we
said it was beautiful you don't really
want to allow that
maybe anish giri his idea ideas to jump
forward with his knight and to threaten
jumping in
once more um for example if black gets
careless then the knight will jump
forward attacking the queen
and attacking the black rook this must
be anish gary's plan but
i don't really like it it feels as if in
the current position he's getting
distracted from the fact he should be
attacking
the black king instead and um okay
it's it's not bad but it's maybe not the
most uh
direct uh way of playing this position
he's aggressive though
yeah yeah but this is what the position
demands it demands
outright violence and there you can see
david
hit it hit the nail on the head the
knight has come into the center and now
there is a very
dangerous attack on the board the threat
is to come in with a knight and just
fork the queen
and the rook just as david and the
bishop
i didn't haven't spotted that one is and
uh it's gonna be
well okay what what would you do if you
were an apology would you simply capture
the bishop or
i'm not so sure i don't think there's
time to capture that bishop if black
plays knight takes bishop right now
then white will continue with that
threat that i just highlighted a moment
ago why would jump in with the knight
and attack the black queen attack the
black brook and winning material and
there we see it
the computer stockfish thinks there's
only one move for black to keep the
balance right now
and that is to move the bishop to cover
the knight's entry square
um for black's bishop to enter the long
diagonal
every other move here moving the bishop
to a different square moving the rook
that would just give white a huge
advantage
over one uh a plus one advantage would
be
almost decisive in this type of position
i think so the move we're looking for if
we bring up the analysis board the move
the computer suggests
is this one the only move to stay in the
game for black
you have to put your bishop here and
cover this important square that the
knight wants to use
so napoli actually he has to find this
move right now
if he wants to maintain the balance if
he wants to avoid giving anishigiri a
huge advantage
at this early stage wow is this one of
those
not obvious moves to a human or should
he find this one no he should find it i
mean the only thing is
whether he thinks his position is really
bad because sometimes when you think
that your position is just
awful and you think well desperate times
call for desperate measures
let's just do something just to get some
activity going because you have to
remember
it is a really sharp position both sides
are gearing up for war
and if if napoleon actually thinks i'm
not in a good place i
cannot defend this then he is going to
do anything he can to get activity and
if that means
sacrificing material so be it so what do
you think david do you think he will
just go for activity or do you think he
would just
calmly make the move you suggested and
just go
i think he'll make that bishop move i
just uh i mean going for something more
active would be nice but i don't see any
way for
uh dunphy actually to get really active
right now black the white king
it is pretty safe and there's no way to
get at it so
um you just have to avoid losing
material in any position i think if you
see your opponent's threat just
um unless you can counter-attack it's
best to just stop that idea and here
there's no way for black to counter
attack so
preventing white's idea of jumping
forward with the knight
i think that's um the only remaining
option napoleon actually
maybe not necessarily deciding upon a
move here just trying to evaluate the
position in a few moves time
for example if the bishop does move as
we suggested then we might see a trade
of bishops
okay yes he finds it a very sensible
move
we do see a trade of bishops and uh
napoli actually the reason he was
thinking for so long on the last move is
he was just trying to evaluate this
position
white's knight can still jump forward it
attacks the black queen but it's only
really a one-move idea there's no
immediate follow-up
for giri i have a question so these
computers
when they evaluate the positions like
they did for yana pomnyacci now
are they uh looking for sort of a way
for him to draw
the game or or will they be looking for
the best
way to win the game um yeah
i think they're just always looking for
the best moves so often they'll say that
one side has the advantage
usually that just means that one side is
creating threats or one side has a
better pawn structure long term
um i mean if it's a plus two plus three
then it means there's actually something
winning
immediately um but for the opponent's
moves they'll just be looking for the
best way to defend or the best way to
fight back
um for the space for the structure
because sometimes
you know the best move to to give
yourself the best possibility for a win
will maybe be
not the best move but something that
will surprise maybe the opponent
exactly so sometimes the best move from
a human point of view won't be their
best
from a computer standpoint and
yeah i mean that's one of the trickiest
things in chess when we're learning we
don't want to look at the computer
valuation
all the time these players i think when
they were learning they were very much
with the board with a book
you need to understand the rules first
before understanding when and when not
to trust the computer
because it is tricky computers they're
good but
yeah they don't explain the plans they
just give you a move and the evaluation
that's
not enough yeah and especially it's the
case if you're losing
the computer will just simply try to
minimize the loss and perhaps give you a
hopeless position
but you know is it when in practical
terms the best thing to do is just throw
caution to the wind and create chaos on
the board which the computer
being a magnificent beast can actually
see everything and see okay this is
refuted
but it doesn't think about the whole
psychological element that
maybe it's actually complicated or maybe
the human will start to feel afraid i
mean
this is the thing with computer chess is
just perfect
yeah exactly i mean i i think you know
in computer championships they even have
to program it to
play very uh openings that are not
popular or they're not in the mainstream
because there actually is a computer
world championship yes there is and they
play
hundreds and hundreds of games against
each other and it's just
perfection but you know they they do
have certain things then
to stop the game just petering out into
a draw because who is the computer world
champion
is it is it stock fish that we are using
here it has been stock fish in the past
i don't think it is
is more of a neural network stockfish is
a man made
program um but yeah
we need to check that um yeah it's
fascinating watching these computer
games though sometimes they will take on
an opening
then the two computers they'll play the
same opening but one with white one with
black so
sometimes the opening is regarded as
just completely lost for black but then
the computers they'll make it playable
they make it look
fully acceptable so yeah very different
type of chess though computer chess
meanwhile anishigiri does lift his rook
up the board
um bit of a strange one maybe i thought
it was time to activate the other rook
first or maybe start pushing those pawns
towards the black king
as we mentioned but um anishigiri plays
a flexible move bringing his rook up the
board maybe clearing
a square clearing some space for his
other rook to join it along an open line
very multi-purpose move like either you
control the center or
if you're feeling a little bit ambitious
you can swing your rook across
do the others called roving work right
and
uh yeah see what you can get up to on
the right side of the board
um what kind of games are your favorite
games because we do have a quiz of the
day where we're asking everyone what is
their favorite
game um yeah so anyone who wants to
enter please
tweet us using the hashtag chesschamps
and
we really love to see pictures so please
if you can
send them to us so david your favorite
game oh my favorite game
that's good it's difficult there's so
many right i think for most
uh for most of us most humans we we
always love those games with lots of
sacrifices because they're so
unexpected and they add the risk factor
and
it's always more dramatic that way but
have you ever played any any games like
that where you've had a king hunter
um i don't know i've played some cool
games but i wouldn't say they're
objectively
perfect or anything there was a game i
played against the dutch international
master a few years ago
but that was very much just one
spectacular idea rather than like a
series of amazing moves
and yeah i don't think my best game is
the best
i've ever seen but out of the classics i
mean
i think we'll see a game a bit later on
between dubov and svana i think that's
one of my favorites
to be honest um i know that every lots
of people they say kasparov against top
love from vikanze yeah that was very
good
as kasparov's immortal yes i mean you
have to say any of the immortals are
worth checking out because they're all
rather beautiful
and uh yeah how about yourself ivanka
what's your
favorite chess game of all time you know
for a long time actually it was the
boring games you know the ones where tea
grand protrusion and carp offer they
just like
stopped their opponents planned because
i thought it took a lot of subtlety but
i do think
that we should go back to the chest
before i answer the question because i
can see that the bar has shot up and i
saw
david change his posture immediately he
sat up and he was like whoa
what happened here what is happening
david i think that janna pontiac
has maybe missed anish giri's threat um
janna pogba is just pushed upon trying
to get to the white king
but now white has an interesting move
i'm not sure it's winning
it's still very complicated so anish
geary he'll have to spend a lot of time
trying to work this out but as we see
below the players cameras there
the computer agrees with me there is one
move that's much stronger than all the
others for white right now
but its consequences are murky it's very
sharp
very risky and that involve that's
because it involves a peace sacrifice
um if we bring up the analysis board we
can see black has just pushed a pawn
forward
if anishigiri is feeling maybe he wants
to play safety first chess
he'll just block this he'll push forward
he won't allow any trades on this side
of the board
and this is completely fine for white we
see it's this computer's second best
suggestion
to block up this side of the board but
if anishgiri
wants to go aggressive after this pawn
push and he's played aggressive moves so
far
then he might consider knight takes pawn
sacrificing to open up the black king
if the black king now takes then this is
pretty much game over
white will jump in with the queen
suddenly a bit of teamwork queen and
rook
um i mean this black king only has one
safe square to go to it has to go back
and suddenly queen takes pawn and at the
very minimum you can capture this knight
maybe you can flick in a check first
maybe you can flick in a check on this
square but at the very least you can
capture this knight and
um it looks like white has a big attack
maybe actually checking first
is the key because wherever the king
goes next move
look the final piece will enter the
attack and the black king
trapped and stranded in the middle of
the board this looks
winning almost for any theory so if he
does play this knight takes pawn move
we will see chaos suddenly napoli
actually he's gonna have to fight for
survival wow
and um so we are looking for this move
by anish giri now
and he finds it he plays it let's see
what the players are looking like on the
camera
instant reply you know he is not
nicknamed the speed demon for nothing
he's just simply captured the pawn and
uh yeah well his uh
king is gonna be in tatters uh
let's just say that you know knight
takes but okay this is
really really sharp actually because
what's what's happening here david can
white simply just capture pawn with
check
yes we do see two moves suggested by the
computer there white
has two moves uh to find actually if he
doesn't find these two moves and he
then black is the one who's in charge
black will be winning
luckily for any those two moves are
probably the most obvious ones as ivanka
mentions white can actually capture a
pawn with check
with his knight attacking the black king
let's show it
um maybe we can keep an eye on the
players as well just in case there are
any big reactions
so in this position white's knight has
jumped in has won a pawn
he can move it again with tempo taking
this pawn check
the pawn cannot capture because this
pawn is pinned
um the white rook pinning this pawn to
the black king the king has to sidestep
maybe towards this side it feels a bit
risky going into the corner
and now i think anishkiri has to capture
this pawn i'm not sure which way maybe
with the rook
maybe with the bishop maybe i mean
probably i would be tempted to capture
the bishop just because you gain a bit
of time against the queen and
meanwhile anishigiri two pawns up his
knight looks a bit odd though and that's
the only potential problem
um in the current position if he doesn't
take this pawn then the only other move
to maintain white's advantage and not
let black win is to actually
capture this pawn with the rook and this
is less obvious
i was as i mentioned it's tempting to
capture with the bishop but
actually capturing with the rook here is
the better move because you challenged
black's rook and now after rook takes
rook
uh wherever the queen goes you can jump
back with the knight and
um it's looks like white is in charge
because black's king is just a bit more
open than whites right now white has won
this important pawn but the game goes on
black can start getting greedy as well
so this type of position very sharp
maybe black white can even sacrifice
anything can happen it's complete chaos
but ani shkiri in the current position
um he has to find either sorry either
rook takes pawn
or knight takes pawn check those are the
two key moves
for white right now all right it's
looking great for a niche gear in the
first game
in the first match of the final and i
want to mention that it's also looking
very good for magnus carlsen in the
first game
in the battle for third place against uh
wesley so
looks on the bar that magnus is winning
this first game
so uh yeah look at that we can see it on
the bottom of the screen magnus crossing
the bar is all the way over to his side
so maybe his mood will get better if he
gets a few weeks i think he
i think he will be chill yeah a bit more
cheerful today i mean his
his interview yesterday was really
emotional i mean i felt
so sad for him of course and it is his
own tournament it is a major he's still
trying to
win one of these right uh champions
chester tournament right
totally you know like you say it is his
own tournament and he's not at the
party to celebrate um yeah that sucks
but he does have an opportunity now to
get that revenge against wesley so after
losing two finals to him
at least winning the the battle for
third place will mean something
um and it is looking good for him in the
first game just as it is for
nhkiri yeah i took a sneak peek at that
game by magnus he played a move on move
four that i've never seen before in my
career in before
before i'm not sure whether it was a
mouse slip or a moment of genius or
something but uh magnus he played an
incredible idea on move four and
yeah just 10 15 moves later he's
completely winning it looks like he's
about to checkmate wesley so
wow wow so maybe we'll have some time to
just
go over that game later i would actually
love that yeah that's
uh i mean magnus maybe it's just helped
him um just to relax a bit knowing that
okay he can't win the tournament but now
the stakes are
less high the pressure's off and um
yeah good start for magnus golson there
yep meanwhile anishiri he's still
thinking
and he does play knight takes pawn one
of the two key moves that we highlighted
the prominently react immediately
and now and he captures with the white
rook
um napoli actually looks confused and
the bar is confused
yes um we did mention that white's uh
using the white route to take that pawn
was one of the best moves on the last
turn
but suddenly maybe it's less good
because white's knight although it's
uh kind of captured two pawns it is
actually trapped on the side of the
board white's knight has no retreat
squares
so there is some danger will anishkiri
end up
losing his knight on the edge of the
board yeah i'm a little bit surprised by
that
i really had even played bishop takes
pawn
on my board just to test out what was
going to happen and
yeah rook takes rick takes pawn didn't
really figure into my radar just because
of that moment
but let's dive into the position and
let's see is
the night trapped yeah let's have a look
is there danger i mean i just love this
kind of complicated
chasse uh where every single move
matters
so so for example if black i mean the
black's rook is under attack right now
from white's rook let's say he captures
because time is everything um i think
white has to capture with the bishop
to gain time against the black queen
otherwise the knight will drop and now
the key move for black maybe is okay
okay we're going to see it we're going
to see it on the board
for black let's see it um he has to move
his queen i would personally protect
this rook i don't like having
weak uh unprotected undefended pieces in
my camp so i would move this queen
across one square
just to keep an eye on this rook if the
black queen goes to the wrong square for
example
okay there's two moves here which are
better than all the others but if it
goes to the wrong square for example if
it gets greedy to try and take this
knight we will see
anish giri's idea to move his bishop to
capture this knight and at the end
there's a check and the loose rook drops
off next move
that's why you have to keep your pieces
protected and the move i would play
personally is
uh just to move shuffle across one
square defend the rook
and now this knight has no retreat
squares what is anish geary planning
here i think his
uh his kind of cunning plan might be to
bring his queen forward
and try to threaten checkmate the black
king almost trapped
but um now um napolita i think he can
simply
capture this knight or even better maybe
drop the queen back
exchange off this queen and then win
white's knight at the end of things he
plays
a movie i don't like it i don't like
that move david because yes it
protects the rook but it allows white to
now
introduce a new piece into the attack
yeah white can now
either now or on the next move yes bring
the rook across and gain time against
the black queen
i think jana pogba pogba's idea after
this move
is to actually um either drop his queen
to this square or
maybe to this one so that's why we see
the computer does suggest
instead of allowing your bishop to be
kind of semi-pinned here
you have to use your bishop first jump
forward and capture this knight
also opening up the idea of a nasty
check and this move looks pretty good
for white but it is
quite a scary one to play it's committal
because suddenly the opponents rook
and bishop are lining up against this
pawn so anish giri
i mean the big question for him will he
find this move is not an
obvious one bishop takes knight right
now that's the only move that gives him
the advantage
and the more natural move i think
bringing the rook across would lead to a
balanced position
this is the one that napoleon is
expecting though bringing the rook
across so
bishop takes knight would be a surprise
for nepali and it takes courage for gary
but it will give white
a big advantage yeah no absolutely david
that is a really
bold move to take that night it's not
instinctive as well you know because
you're simply
playing into black's hands but i mean i
shall we show the shall we show you the
reason why it's so good
it's just that you know i just love
these kind of positions where it's just
follow the checks so uh so i think the
reason why it's so good
is because after bishop takes knight
black will have to go bishop takes
bishop and now we can
get checking so the queen can check and
now the black king has to step forward
and now we check with the knight and the
imprisoned knight is out
and uh the king moves put it anywhere
yeah exactly and now i can take your
bishop yep now you take the bishop and
all you need to do is account
exactly five pawns against three pawns
white is two pawns ahead and black has a
weak king so white should win this game
um i think that's why anish giri i mean
the reason he's paused here is because
he's seen this move
chess players the first thing we look
for in any position are checks and
captures this bishop move
is a capture it forces black's reply so
it is possible
to calculate the answer look at anish
giri's face as well leaning forward
focused
he's working out the consequences of
this check um i think
the probability's only saving grace is
potentially to block with this bishop
and it's still very complicated this
position but white does have time
to retreat his knight so looking good
for gary will he
find this key move will he find bishop
takes knight right now yeah he has to
override those instincts to kind of
not calculate everything and just kind
of play the most
natural most friendly move that your
hand
just really wants to automatically play
but
you know this is what you have to train
on you have to train on
force you know on your checks your
captures and your attacks
once you get that into kind of like
automatic mode then it just really kind
of clicks into place
and you immediately improve it and uh
talking about
improvement uh okay we'll deal with it
now okay so he's actually has happened
wow actually we do reach that position
that i pointed out just at the very end
there
of the analysis um white did go for that
check he did
find a way to retreat his knight so now
that white has saved his knight
he's two pawns up anishigiri with two
extra pawns
and remember as well queen and knight
are the ideal attacking combo if white
can coordinate the queen and knight if
he can maybe trade off the rooks as well
later on
then white should just be winning this
game napoli actually he has to play for
tricks now he has to get to the white
king that's the only way he will save
this game
uh napoli actually okay and then we do
see the best moves the
top computer suggestions are to move the
black rook
there's a few squares they're all viable
but the black rook is
kind of eyed up by that white queen
right now
it should move it should relocate itself
and the best move actually is to attack
the white queen
with the black crook and magnus carlsen
he has won
that first game in the battle for first
third place
against wesley so and apparently it's a
very spectacular year so we'll have
david
take us through that fantastic game um
when this one is done and i have to say
they're spending quite a lot of time in
this one anish only two minutes left on
his clock
napoleon actually a little bit more but
are we seeing the nerves really coming
into play here
yeah i think especially over the last
few moves aneesh giri i can't fault his
play
he's found some really interesting ideas
um and he's been brave
with his moves but it has taken him a
lot of time um
so yep a little bit of nerves maybe just
slowing him down slightly but
it hasn't affected his actual moves on
the board and that's the key thing right
now
having two minutes on the clock it
should be sufficient to play this
position because
lots of trades have happened and um the
more it gets simplified the more
white's two extra pawns will come to
um decide the game they will start to
make their mark
and that's why napoleon is thinking
right now he realizes he's in a little
bit of trouble
it's not game over there's still some
chances because white's king is not
entirely safe either
but napoleon actually he is the one
kind of the burdens on him now to
justify his two-pawn deficit
and um okay he does make uh move with
his rook attacking the white queen
we did see that that was the computer's
top suggestion and the queen does
sidestep
so what now then he must have uh got a
clear plan for for the next move then
probably because he would you know he
knew that anish would move his queen
right yeah and he knew he would have
moved it there as well i think that's
the only safe square really
um if white's queen had gone to another
square then it wouldn't have kept an eye
on the black bishop so
white um black also possibly would come
over and give check
and then take the white knight but he
couldn't because he had to keep an eye
on his bishop so
yeah you're right kaya he had to have
foreseen that he does play relatively
quickly
um a king move um maybe not the move
that
kind of he wanted to play but um it does
at least step out of the pin
along that top rank and you can perhaps
release the queen for
a move you know because there are some
ideas in the
air especially revolving around the
white king because the white king isn't
especially safe
it's standing exposed on a diagonal and
if you look at the two pawns in front
you can kind of see it's a scenario
where
the king could perhaps get mated on the
back rank yeah those are the things that
you know you
you have to be very positive about your
position and you're thinking well
whilst the queens are still on the board
the danger is that
there is still hope yeah if we bring up
the analysis board just to
illustrate your banker's point um for
example here if white gets careless um
actually the first move that i would
play
is just to push my pawn up to defend my
knight you don't want to allow any
uh potential checks um attacking the
king and attacking the knight winning a
piece so i would just defend this knight
um okay and he does this in a different
way but that doesn't change the fact
that ivanka you mentioned
maybe black will be tempted to give a
check and drop his queen down and the
threat now is to bring the rook the
whole way
down and catch this black this white
king in the corner so say for instance
here
white is like i don't know what you're
doing i'm just gonna yeah it just makes
a random move then the rook
comes down yeah and back rank checkmate
the king caught behind its own pawns
so this is the type of thing the
tomiachi is aiming for but anishiri
um okay we do see this maybe happen on
the board
um anishigiri if this happens maybe the
safest thing to do here
would be uh to keep things simple just
push a pawn create some breathing space
for your king if you want to play it
super safe then you bring your rook
across and kind of
keep this king nicely protected but now
wow and a sneaky sneaky threat by um
janna pomenti after giving this check
he brings his queen back look at this at
the moment there's a bit of tension here
if white gets careless again just pushes
a pawn then suddenly check
um it looks like a blunder losing the
rook but suddenly
this diagonal is opened up and black
wins the opponent's queen so
uh every side creating threats right now
um
black is threatening to win the white
queen indirectly so white should move
this uh
well he has to move this piece right now
and it should be surely
won't miss that attack yeah i wonder
whether he's going to get sneaky and try
to
kind of outs out sneaker
how would you out sneak the ponytail by
moving my knights
um yes well that is very sneaky
attacking the queen and rook takes
knight is impossible because of queen
takes queen
um 20 seconds very sneaky
um okay the current position yep 20
seconds let's go back to the players
cameras because
is any showing signs of stress here with
only 15 seconds left on the club yeah
let's check them out
okay so he's certainly done a safety
first approach i quite like it
but it does allow one thing that the
bishop now has moved from a really
passive square
and now it's on the most perfect
diagonal that
they it can be it can be on the long
diagonal and it's pointing at a pawn
and suddenly i'm thinking napolita's
position is bad
but it's not that bad yeah he's fighting
back at least he has chances and
um white now i did mention this move a
few moments ago it's very much the type
of move you don't want to have to play
but sometimes needs must and um why it's
brooke now playing a purely passive role
defending a pawn
near the white king it feels like anish
giri he's gone into kind of retreat mode
five seconds okay wow that is
look at napoleon's face he's surprised
by that last one by nishikiri
yes he needs to create some space for
his king but that is really
playing with fire and ishgari suddenly
that white pawn could become a target
if you imagine black's rook if it's not
currently able to attack the white queen
but if it can sidestep
and drop itself onto that b line
suddenly it has so many targets
white's king is in huge trouble right
now um
still no immediate threat no immediate
way to
kind of break through for napolita but
um anishigiri
with 16 seconds and a horribly weak king
the last few moves have gone against him
for sure
i think he just shouldn't have allowed
black bishop to activate itself
suddenly black is in the ascendancy
ignore what the computer says
black is the one creating threats right
now and he drops his queen back
that is to line up with the rook so the
rook now wants to step across one square
to attack the white queen
and uh okay
napoli actually frowning um maybe
underestimating that last move by white
that's a very
nice idea by energy just putting his
king on a light square
note that all of uh note that black's
bishop is on dark squares so you can't
leave your king on a dark square as well
certainly he's getting ready to put
everything on the light squares
he's getting ready to bring his knight
over as well to push a pawn onto a light
square
um and it's consolidating um
i don't like what napoleon actually did
kind of forcing any giri to find the
right plan
sometimes you have to keep your opponent
guessing give them a huge amount of
choice but napoli actually kind of
forced white to put his queen on a
better square
gave white time to improve the white
king um okay
and upon the actually he just made a
pretty much a one-move threat
and it didn't really work so he needs to
find a new idea right now
um yeah anishgiri i said it was going in
the wrong direction for him those last
two moves he would have been happy with
though
and he's back up to almost 30 seconds
yes
but still 30 seconds does mean the clock
is ticking down
and there isn't much time and when there
isn't much time
that induces one thing and one thing i
only panic and
i don't know i do really like what anish
has done but at the same time
i can see it going wrong for him in a
kind of quiet severe way
okay so what how i personally would
start now harassing
the the white queen yep it's tempting to
harass that white queen
and we do see the computer suggestions
it actually the computer wants to
drop the black rook down and start
attacking a pawn yeah but uh okay the
second boot best move is to attack the
white queen well okay
this is not a move that i actually
wanted to see on the board i mean what
is the palmy actually doing
he's two pawns down he needs to create
chaos i mean what is the king doing
there
can whites now simply just make some
moves okay
i love this next move by anish and now
all you're going to do is sidestep
with the rook and start harassing the
black
king no this is really a bad turn of
events
yeah i mean that move by napoli actually
it was just pure
panic or pure inertia he didn't want to
do anything he didn't want to change
anything but instead he had to
i mean going back with the king that
king wants to be towards the center if
it gets to an end game
that king wasn't a target so napoli
actually essentially just throwing away
a move just giving anish a free move
to do something useful and unleash his
put pawns on lights look all of white's
pieces and pawns
on that left side of the board they're
all on light squares that is instructive
everyone if your opponent has a dark
squared bishop put everything on light
squares the black bishop now is hitting
thin air
it was such a powerful piece like four
moves five moves ago but
now that black bishop it's just
superfluous it doesn't have any point
yes and look at this anishi he's going
active with his rook
um okay the black queen eyeing up one of
white's pawns down there on that right
side so and he keeps everything nice
exactly everything on the light squares
i just absolutely love it
and what we can expect now is we're
gonna perhaps expect a niche just to do
what i kind of call david howell
strategy which is just to wait and see
just make a few moves and then slowly
start to improve the position
because you don't need to make anything
committal until you've built up time on
the clock
yeah and anish is building time on the
clock he's up to 45 seconds now
um remember a few moves ago it looked
like the white king was under fire
and each down to six seconds at one
point but now he's up to 45 he's making
moves very simple moves keeping
everything protected
everything on light squares anishigori
he's using that kind of strategic eye
that he has
um just to consolidate and remember
still
a two-pawn advantage for white um
napoli actually it feels like he's
running out of plans his clock is
ticking down
he keeps creating these one move threats
they keep getting refuted
um they're they're just not working
simply and then
it's back to square one for him i mean
i'm impressed by napoleon actually poker
face that's the one thing i will say
because
usually in such such uh situations when
he knows that he's in trouble
he's quite expressive this time he's
okay
he's finally starting to frown but um
this time yep big trouble for black now
there's simply no useful move and the
reason the computer says plus 2.5 for
white is because white has two extra
pawns
if the queens disappear if the rooks
disappear it's just game over
right exactly david and if you look at
who's controlling the lines
i mean it's just going to be white and
napoli actually is just
sidestepping with his king okay but
this is like he's just waiting for the
axe to fall look at that javance
the final pawn that was on a dart square
has now pushed up everything for white
is on a light square
this is if he's playing checkers but i
know checkers is all on dart squares but
he's as if he's playing checkers
um that is really nice strategy for
managiri the black bishop
simply doesn't know what to do and there
we see the rooks do
disappear so queen and knight usually
outmatch queen and bishop
there is some small danger if black's
able to line up his queen and bishop
along the same diagonal
but initially he should have this
covered look he goes to try and trade
off
his knight for the bishop yeah also
really importantly he covers that square
that you want that
maybe nepali actually really wanted to
align the queen and the bishop on the
diagonal together and try to pass the
napoleon sorry giri on the dark squares
but
calm response by uh anish
i personally i would not necessarily
have given black this past pawn black
actually has a passport in the center of
the board
and also remember um magnus carlsen
against janna pomney yesterday and the
day before in their semi-finals they had
so many queen end games
napoli actually always did well in those
queen end games napoli actually
he's very good at maneuvering the queens
using the past pawns using the queens to
support those past borns
and here the black bishop currently
dominating the white knight
it's not over yet uh napoli actually
expert in these queen end games he still
has a chance white's knight
nicely positioned but slightly offside
right now and okay it's time to start
running with the pawns for nickieri
um he's coordinated everything well he's
still winning but
from his he has to not allow any checks
against that white king white king still
slightly exposed
if the black queen can get into that
white camp
so i'm not writing off napoliyachi yet
the bars are
not liking anisha's last move yeah um
i think it's not just the last move it's
maybe a series of moves
um maybe he just aimed for that
simplicity a bit too soon
aiming to um trade off those rooks when
he didn't need to okay anishiri now
three pawns up
but is it enough maybe he's put his
knight on a bad square and now suddenly
black is going on the attack
um napoli actually has he found a
miraculous escape
uh i'm trying to work out how white can
save his king now
um can you retreat with the queen can
you simply just
uh step step diagonally to the queen and
then and then
you might get checkmated javanka if you
are not careful um
black is simply black's got two threats
one to drop the queen down once get
square and give check to the white king
the other one is to bring the bishop
down and okay threaten
checkmate and anishgiri is he just going
for the draw here
no no way he has to he has one more
check here so he can check and
centralize his queen okay white will
centralize his queen but the problem is
the knight is just not participating in
the game right now yeah the white queen
and white knight they're just one move
too slow
to coordinate and threaten the black
king meanwhile the white king is the
the real target i think yeah uh i think
yana pogba
has found a genius uh way to
save this game um wow that would be
absolutely unbelievable
is there any chances for nepo to win
this yes well david david says yes
if he's careless with the queen and
doesn't take the draw then
then danish gets too ambitious now yes
it will be so heartbreaking for anish if
he knows that he was winning three pawns
up and he might have
but it's very tempting here just to
simply just move two squares
to the left with the queen in 10 seconds
well the king can go on the dark squares
and uh that will be it
okay he's going to give a few more if
white has gone for that one
okay ivanka um maybe not lost but okay
this is the second time we've reached
this position um the position has
repeated itself
if any gary continues to give checks
with this queen the game is a draw the
problem is the white king is too exposed
um right now black still has threats
against that white king
um he just needs his knight to be able
to defend but is too far away from the
white king right now
okay gary he's going for the draw he's
given a check and
if he gives check now third time we've
reached this position the game is a draw
okay wow the first game in the final
between yonder pogba and anish giri is a
draw but it's not a
dull draw this was a dramatic game it
definitely could have ended with a win
i mean for for both of them but it look
it was looking
really good for anish geary who was just
sitting down by the computer he wanted
to look
over this do you think he's disappointed
now david yeah
for sure anishikari i mean he was in
charge throughout the whole game he
found some really nice ideas he was the
one who initiated all the
kind of complications the whole kind of
melee and um
in the end just when victory was within
his grasp two extra pawns
he rushed slightly and napoleon came up
with a fantastic idea to draw
um it all started in this position with
anishigiri if we do a count he's two
pawns up
white has two extra pawns but he rushed
here he played rook takes rook
maybe unnecessarily giving black a past
pawn in the middle of the board
it wasn't so bad for anish he still two
pawns up he still should be winning this
game
but in this position it started to go
slightly wrong and especially here
this move was simply not improving the
white position
and now napoli actually went on the
attack anishigiri went
three pawns up but the reason he had to
take a draw in this position
is because black has two huge threats
one of them is to drop the queen down
give check to the white king and the
other maybe more pertinent threat
is to bring the bishop down for example
if white continues making a move
then suddenly the bishop and queen line
up checkmate
is coming and the white king is almost
trapped this is why anishigiri in the
final position
had to take the draw we saw him give a
few checks
and there was no way to check mate there
was no way to continue
and the game repeated itself
the first game ended with a draw in 14
minutes we're going to have the second
game in the final between yonder pontiac
and anish geary
still three games to go in the first
match in
the final and then later on in a few
minutes we're gonna show you the next
chapter
in the magnus carlsen story when he
became a world champion
and very exciting after the next game we
have the next magnus carlsen
celebrity charity chess challenge with
cuba
gooding jr hi i'm about to challenge the
digital version of the world chess
champion magnus carlson
at age 10. i mean
rude will i beat him yeah this is
intense will he demolish me
i didn't see it even coming when he
stole my night i was like what the hell
about gooding jr what a fantastic person
with so much energy
you guys have to look forward to the
celebrity challenge with him coming up
after the next game
all right but uh there's not only the
final going on there's also a battle
for third place and you were talking
about the first game with magnus carlsen
and wesley so
being uh spectacular and magnus won it
could you maybe show us david what
happened here i mean so many amazing
moments just in that one game magnus
carlsen
back to his best in blistering form he
just
i mean he just wiped the floor with
wesley so in this game
um and it all started here in this
position a very traditional opening
king's pawn opening
we call this the four nights whoops
because
yeah the four knights because all of the
four knights have developed themselves
and here white has many normal moves you
can push this pawn
uh you can bring your bishop out obeying
all the normal rules of chess
magnus carlsen he shocked the chess will
hold it he shocked wesley so
by pushing a pawn on the corner of the
board ivanka have you ever seen this one
before
[Laughter]
is this a mouse slip um personally i've
played this pawn push before i've moved
my pawn one square but
magnus carson pushing it two squares and
this did surprise
wesley so a few moves later we saw in
this
position uh magnus carlsen trying to go
on the attack and he came up with
another surprising
and unusual shocking move here um he
i mean this must have thrown wesley so
out of his seat white
bringing his knight deep into the black
camp attacking this rook trapping his
own knight
and a few moves later we saw that this
night sacrificed itself
um check this is a fork it has to be
captured this night and suddenly the
white queen jumped into the position
magnus carlton a whole night down
but as we saw later on the queen and the
bishops
combined to deliver checkmate i just
want to show you guys the final position
because look at this the bishop uh
pinning the black knight
the white queen about to dive into the
position these two guys attacking
and magnus brought a final attacker into
the game
he lifted his rook up the board bringing
it across and
yeah we did see checkmate on the board
magnus carson gave a check
and actually wesley so resigned just
before he lifted his king
and walked into the middle of the board
walked into this checkmate
magnus carlsen he played like mikhail
tal there a series of spectacular
sacrifices and this is magnus's reaction
after well just as he's winning this
game with a huge smile on his face
is this just the best way to win a game
in a pressured situation david yeah i
mean that's the best way to bounce back
from a
from a setback uh from a defeat
yesterday um that could have been i mean
that's probably one of the best games
he's played in the last six months
magnus carson and uh
to do it today of all days will feel
satisfying yeah
he definitely enjoyed himself magnus
carlsen he is ahead in the battle
for third place against wesley so now
we're also gonna enjoy ourselves
with a puzzle today simon made a bunch
of puzzles
and this is puzzle for day eight
hello again viewers it's time for my
puzzle of the day
hopefully you're getting used to these
puzzles now and
it's giving you something to get your
own gray matter
whirling working should we say it's one
thing watching
chess but you gotta use that knowledge
to become a better chess player
now these puzzles are also over on
chessable
so if you want to have a look at these
ones we've got in the show and some
other puzzles there's a free course
there now
here we see denial duboff with the white
pieces
playing against erasmus spain in the
european team championships in 2019
now daniel duboff as i'm sure most of
you are aware is a real
crowd favorite at the moment one of my
favorite players
he's incredibly imaginative he's
really brave he's really a leader rather
than a follower
a lot of chess players sort of copy
established theory opening ideas
but what i like about duboff is that he
he's a creator he leads the way he comes
up with his
own concepts very creative player
and this just emphasizes this position
here that creativity now
he has the white pieces and again it's
all about the opponent's king
what is that king doing there well
daniel has
chased it down the board but we've got
to finish it off
so have a think how you can finish that
king off in this position there's no
good
checks so the little rule i save there's
no good checks look for captures
and then the next thing you should look
at and that's what we want to look at
here
is frets so look at ways you can create
deadly threats
like checkmate in the position even if
it
allows your opponent to capture
something uh look for those
key moves and good luck i'll bring you
the answer
later on and you find this puzzle
on champion's chess for instagram on
twitter facebook so you can work on
it throughout the broadcast simon will
be with us later to give you the answer
and you actually said david that this
could be one of the
uh best chess games you've ever seen
yeah for sure the position that simon
showed
um it's kind of the finale after a
spectacular game
it's a whole king hunt if you notice
black's king here
um this is the a3 square it's deep in
white's territory and actually
much earlier on in the game black had
actually castled the king black's king
of course starting in the middle of the
board
but the king castled and then it went on
this journey it literally walked
the whole way up the board and this is
kind of the finale the final blow
and yes this is the puzzle for you guys
at home how do you
get to this black king as simon
mentioned it's all about looking for
threats
that's the key and good luck yep
good luck everyone now we have arrived
at the next chapter
in the chess story of magnus calls now
at 22
he became the highest rated chess player
of all time
uh and a year later he finally became
the 16th world chess champion but it is
a title
that weighs heavy on him and he has
struggled ever since to not lose his
title
the world chess championship bubble
that's something quite unique
and if it goes too long without you kind
of
you start to long to get back there even
though you know that
it's very hard it's very frustrating
it's a kind of a
love-hate relationship at a very high
level
that's some of his world championship
trophies small ones from
blitz and rapid typically and
then some of the major trophies the 2013
one is not here
magnus carlsen this is his first
world championship match
[Music]
[Applause]
this was a larger than life experience
you have this
exotic feel the smells the noise
it's so overwhelming and together with
hundreds of journalists it was
such an uh mesmerizing
experience a team of grandmasters knows
everything about magnus
carlsen and their
[Music]
i think i said after the match that well
now i can die
we had a nice celebration and it was a
very happy night for everyone involved
when he won in the end uh but at that
point he
he he was already there mentally in a
way i mean this was his to win
and it was like a force
that we didn't expect to stop in every
match since that
he's been the defending champion
defending
his title how is it different those
matches it's very different
because in the first you have something
to achieve that you haven't achieved
before
after that you either repeat or
fall back down and psychologically
that's much more difficult
but here we have the 2014
sochi world championship trophy
that was a little bit more difficult to
get motivated for that match
but fortunately he managed to get
motivated and to do the work
and then 2016 yeah that was very intense
yeah i think he lost was a game eight i
think
and they had seven draws before that
magnus felt that
against karjakin the only acceptable
outcome was to win
not only because he hates to lose but it
was just simply unacceptable to lose and
he was down one game at one point
i think in the first half of the match
he was kind of in a good mood and
feeling that okay if i just continue to
play this well he will eventually crack
at some point and i will get in
a win but then when it didn't happen he
was really frustrated and
he was like second guessing what what am
i doing before the
games that's also a sign that you're
losing a little bit of your
self-confidence
we went to restaurant and someone
started to
serve some drinks and it took off a
little bit from there
we were depressed and it was difficult
we didn't know what to talk about
when we arrived at the restaurant but
after an hour or something we were
all laughing and we just had a hilarious
evening
and maybe that helped kind of on the
nervous system
for uh yeah i think he won the 10th game
and then
from there he was in control and then
this should be the
2018 one
2018 karana that was a tough one
he'd had he'd had a great year i didn't
i hadn't had a great year
and it felt when we were playing like we
were we were equals
and in that sense like the other
matches it's felt like losing is simply
not an option like
it cannot happen obviously that's not a
not an attitude that is good if you want
to have
an enjoyable experience but
the match in london was a little bit
different in in that sense
it was an equal match and if i'd lost it
it would have
it would have hurt a great deal but
still it didn't feel like it was
it was impossible something that that
that couldn't happen
we have some more stuff downstairs but
uh well
magnus is not really resting on his
laurels it's really
always the next tournament is the most
important
yeah what is next for magnus carlsen the
current world chess
champion he is not in the final in the
magnus carlson invitational
is fighting for third place but anish
kiri and janupomnyachi
they are heading into game two in the
first match
in the final the first one ended up with
a draw so this one is going to be an
exciting one with jana ponnyacci
having the white pieces david and
anish he had big chances in the last one
so will he be coming into this
disappointed or do you think he's going
to be hungry for more i think the older
niche might have been disappointed
this new modern mature manish he seems
focused
he's in the moment i think anisha will
be hungry to take advantage of
future chances which will come and then
apogee with the
white pieces um you say ivanka he's
never going for the quick draws he's you
know he's
he's a fighter he's playing fantastic
chess yes so
what do we expect in this first white
game of his in the final well he will be
you know he's quite an understated guy
but you know
inside he will be absolutely ecstatic
but he saved
such a losing position and perhaps he
was two pawns down
so he will be feeling very confident and
he'll be getting ready for the next game
and we're going to see a real battle on
our hands and it's going to be
absolutely amazing because both these
players
have an uncompromising style they just
love to play aggressive chess we are
waiting for anish uh
geary to come to the table for the
second game
we do know that both of these players
are fighting in the candidates
tournament
tournament that will resume in exactly
one month
i think and uh they are both looking
really good there one of these two
could be the next opponent for magnus
carlsen in the world chess
championship that will start in november
this year if it was to be one of these
two david yep who's your bet on
i think in the pontiac in the candidates
i mean he's got a point more than and
he's going into the second half
he has to be the favorite to qualify but
in terms of who would give magnus a
better match i think
ah i don't know actually both of them
would give yeah i know i know uh
right and uh napoli actually he showed
he can beat magnus in the past okay
meanwhile anishiguri choosing the
sicilian najdorf
remember that's one of the prizes for
the quiz of the day uh anish giri's
chesabal
nadorf course so he is putting his
money where his mouth is and he is
playing the opening that he suggests and
wow
ivanka one of the most critical
uh lines of the night of the poisoned
pawn variation oh it's going to get kyle
to guess how old
sorry i would never guessed it
black has grabbed a pawn with his queen
we said we used to say it was poisoned
because it's just so dangerous black
queen losing so much time um in the
process of grabbing that pawn
so black currently a porn up but look at
the black queen misplaced white
pieces are already primed um they are
ready to start attacking and this one
is it's as if black is walking a
tightrope i've always felt yes
um i would never even dream of playing
this is black maxine bachelor
and tata steel was resoundly and
he was absolutely destroyed by
absolutely everyone in this variation
and after that he's kind of stopped
playing it it was just too dangerous
so i'm really looking forward to seeing
what a niche will bring to the table
you also have to remember they will
actually face each other again
in one month's time and of course anish
being one point behind napoli actually
needs to take that point
yeah i remember when i was growing up um
watching the games of english
grandmaster nigel short he used to play
the white side of this all the time give
up
pawn and gamble everything on the attack
and i mean historically even
before that um there were players i mean
fisher fought uh
fought out this variation in the past um
there were
a set of argentinian players who are
kind of using this
uh on a constant basis pologyevsky
himself
um also using this line as black it's so
much history behind this opening and
okay we do see a set of trades
black's bishop coming out um yep this is
still
well-known stuff and ishkiri deep in
preparation
i mean this is interesting because
clearly both players they know this
they've done their homework they both
play the night off as black
but it will come down to a battle of
memory
who can remember what they've analyzed
with the computer and maybe creativity
because remember it's not just what the
computer says if both sides end up
memorizing the top computer line it's
just going to be a draw chess in the end
is um well should be a balance game
um it's about finding a way to surprise
your opponent first and get them into a
position where it's hard for humans to
um kind of evaluate and hard for them to
handle the
imbalances because this position is full
of imbalances
the first thing i would do for white
maybe take off that bishop bring out my
light square bishop and get the white
king to safety because black's king
will take longer yeah that is the
instinctive move
yeah and exactly and whilst the uh was
the
is thinking about this let's remind
everyone at home that we
are running a quiz and our question of
the day
is what is your favorite chess game
and you can tweet your answers using the
hashtag
chesschamps and of course we absolutely
adore
seeing your pictures but i do have to
show you some of our entries
we have one from mohamed el ebiri who
says
it's october 17 1956 can you start
guessing david
when donald byrne faced the great bobby
fischer in the game known as the game of
the century
it's when the world has been shaken by
the 17th move for black
bishop e6 how old is bobby fisher here
he was
he was really young um he was a teenager
i think this
this picture it isn't from that game but
um
because the position on the board
doesn't match with the game of the
century but wow
but yeah in the game that is um kind of
referred to by muhammad
uh bobby fischer he was 13 years old and
he sacrificed his queen he
he found a series of yeah it was
absolutely
brilliant yeah and we also have an entry
from jessica that we particularly liked
says any game oh no hang on that was
michael okay so i'll go to
michael and he says that let me just
read it thirteen-year-old magnus versus
casper of aside from the oppressive game
the psychological aspects of the game
are second to none
yeah that is a very cute picture of uh
michael of mike
well magnus playing gary kasparov and we
had a we had the interview with
magnus's sister alan saying that it was
so absurd to be there and seeing this
13 year old magnus it wasn't really 12
for his age as well
just standing there with casparo and all
these super grandmasters analyzing and
yeah no i mean it's a great moment yeah
as michael landino's points out
it really was fantastic and i also know
i looked at the game and studied the
game
kasparov was a little bit on the back
foot as well and
magnus later kicked himself actually for
not
for not actually choosing the most
critical move he said you know he just
didn't believe
that uh he could beat casper off wow
and uh finally before we take the move
just want to show you one from
jessica and jessica says any game where
there is chaos on the ball
and talking about chaos on the board we
should go back to the game because there
is indeed chaos on the board
everything is heating up yep everything
is indeed heating up
anishigiri now he's looking down towards
the left that's because he's just
trying to remember his analysis
meanwhile i did mention this is the
poisoned pawn variation
white sacrifices are born very early on
but white has now regained that pawn if
you look at white's rook
it's one of the most active rooks you'll
ever see especially
at move 14 and uh meanwhile anjiri
he's trying to fight against that active
rook by bringing his bishop forward he
can't castle yet anishigiri but the plan
is to get the king to safety whoever
gets their king to safety first will
have the advantage
look at this image of these two players
in the finals that is so intense
both of them already in deep deep
concentration deep calculation here
yep memorization i think in terms of uh
anishigiri um so far look at anishgiri's
clock time
16 minutes he's been playing with
confidence probably the whole of this
morning he was just studying
openings he was maybe even going through
his own chessable course
revising the lines um chess sometimes
it's a bit like an exam beforehand if
you know what's about to come up you
might as well revise beforehand
and um oh but i just i just love this
image of these two players yesterday
there was a game
yeah exactly because yesterday there was
a game with a beautiful pawn structure
that i wanted to hang on the wall and
now i just want to picture
that exact picture i want on my wall
just reminds me of what we think is so
mesmerizing about
chess just two brilliant brains up
against each other
two big brains that's right and uh
napoli actually just from his body
language
i mean not looking at the okay now he is
looking at the screen as soon as i'm
about to say it but
from a couple of minutes he wasn't
looking at the screen and that just says
to me that he has studied this position
before he knows he studied it before but
he can't quite remember it's not fresh
in his mind
and in the end he does move his bishop
out and anishigiri frowns
so maybe not the move david it
definitely is not the move actually what
a niche did by capturing the pawn with
the bishop was actually totally rare
i mean the main move is actually to
capture that pawn with a pawn
and uh so what anish is was expecting
was
that the light squared bishop would
actually jump up one square
forward and start challenging its
counterpart
and uh instead well
napoli actually has taken the game into
the realm of the unknown this is what i
love about chess
you know anish would have spent hours
and hours and hours on this position
but he's surprised and now he's on his
own and uh
isn't that the great thing yeah that's a
good thing if your opponent is very well
prepared if you can sense that they're
playing every move instantly
if you just get this uh yeah this
feeling that they know exactly what
they're doing that they've memorized it
all before
then sometimes the best thing to do is
not look for the best move
look for a good enough move but that
will throw them out of their
comfort zone they'll throw them out of
their previous preparation
um if we bring up the analysis board we
can see why anish giri is so deep in
thought right now
white bringing the bishop forward to
this square a bit of a passive square as
ivanka mentions bringing the bishop one
square further
was maybe the most well-known move
challenging this
black bishop but okay anish has to find
a new idea now and
ideally he wants to castle his king the
black king wants to castle a way to
safety but if you castle the king you no
longer protect this bishop in the middle
of the board white's
rook would just snap it off and white
would be winning that's why anish giri
he has to prepare the idea of castling
as king
by first securing this bishop will he do
this by moving the bishop back will he
do it
in a different way maybe kicking the
white rook away from this attack
either way anishigiri he has to find a
way to save this bishop because the
black king
should not stay in the center much
longer the move that i would be
attracted to
is possibly bringing the queen back
eyeing up this bishop
along the board or to try and kick this
bishop back in a different way
attack it with a pawn um anishigiri he's
got a lot to think about because
white is ready to castle next move white
is ready to get the king to safety
and if black cannot do the same then
it's going to spell
trouble mm-hmm yeah no it's it's
certainly
such a fiery position and uh napoleon
i think he's quite satisfied with his
move and i think you get some kind of
certain
satisfaction or maybe a big sigh of
relief
after you know that you've kind of
tricked your opponent out of his own
preparation
yeah i think yeah in practical terms if
if your opponent is better prepared than
you and you're aware of that then
um the only moral victory you can
achieve is
getting kind of surprising them exactly
um
the only priority should be to survive
uh the opening stage and outplay them a
bit later on and
um janapoli actually he has done that he
survived the opening stage and he's
given
gary a big question to answer yeah so i
would be tempted uh if i were playing
with the black pieces i mean this is a
totally wild position it's in a
different style than i particularly like
but i would be tempted just to push that
pawn forward and attack the bishop
just ask the question what are you gonna
do where are you gonna go
as i mentioned that was one of the uh
most yes
obvious moves for black that white
bishop would have to commit itself and
then giri would buy himself a bit more
time to
uh to figure out a plan or how to react
shall we do a deep dive and have a look
what can anish do what is he thinking
about
and uh so we suspect that the first move
uh david said it was the most natural it
certainly
appeals to me as well just attack the
bishop by yourself
one move and the bishop has to relocate
itself
on the same diagonal so let's put it on
a random square
but the reason you shouldn't kind of
maintain this diagonal
or probably shouldn't is because
suddenly you've lost control of this
square
and suddenly you have to worry about the
black queen coming in and giving check
maybe not immediately but at least over
the next couple of moves this is a
scary idea to allow so as you mentioned
ivanka
where along this diagonal do you drop
back to do you just drop back one square
maybe
eye up this pawn uh in the long term
yes you have a wealth of choice don't
you three three choices i mean
i was actually taking inspiration from
you
yeah exactly just in case black wanted
to defer any decision making
one extra move by moving the rook okay i
guess the most important
question ivanka as i mentioned is how do
you ever get castled as black how do you
deal with this bishop
being under fire from the white rook
yeah well this is why you played as a
sicilian you know
you're not that fussed about kings okay
well let's get into this
exactly i think if in doubt anishi he'll
play a move later such as queen to this
square
get the queens off and then it doesn't
matter that your king is in the middle
it will no longer get checkmated so okay
this is the current position
first question is from the pontiac how
to deal with this bishop being under
threat
next question for any giri he'll react
by trying to get his king to safety
mm-hmm yeah definitely definitely some
choices
for for nepal niati to face and
uh well what is i mean do you think this
has become going to become a favorite
game
quite possibly might be our favorite
final
so far of the tour if the players
continue in this fighting uh
fighting spirit this fighting fashion
yeah i agree with that
you know i really didn't expect anything
like this at all
but you know you have to remember you
kind of said it quite a few times that
anishi giri has has written
written recorded has recorded a
a video series on the night off for
chessable so he is a big expert but he's
also meeting in pomneichi who's also
a huge expert and one of the
disadvantages of writing
of uh recording such a series is that
people can
compare notes out there in the public
domain all of your ideas well okay
anish decided to play my move which was
it wasn't the most aggressive move i was
just thinking
about david's philosophy that no piece
should be left unprotected that you
should simply
just kind of harmonize everything but
okay
what's the stop nope omni actually from
saying let's exchange queens
uh from gary from saying that sorry gary
sorry yeah yeah i don't think there's
anything stopping him from saying that
that's
i mean i would be uh i mean it's not the
bravest move in the world but i would be
trying to
change those queens immediately i would
be trying to offer that trade because
um if you can't castle as black then the
question is what else simply and i don't
see any other
productive idea white remember is ready
to castle
and uh therefore white is slightly ahead
in the race for development
and normally if you're behind a
development or if your king is about to
get attacked then trading queens is just
a good long-term
idea and um we said we've seen it before
in the in the semi-finals yesterday
and in the finals napolita he's great in
the queen end games
so get the queens off and head for a
different type of end game that might be
a sensible um
idea for giri i mean the thing though
about this opening
and the last game as well that really
kind of captures my imagination is just
the fact that
neither player is caring about the
candidates so far they're not afraid to
show their secrets
they're playing their best openings the
most critical openings
um i mean that just shows the prestige
of this tournament they
care so much about winning this final
that's their only goal right now
i don't think either of them are
thinking about that uh candidates
obviously they're only going to face
each other once more in the candidates
they already played once and and they
because there is a round robin for
right but do you think all the seconds
out there and all
and all the players and the candidates
will be paying attention to this and
and the entire magnus crossing
invitational for those players
uh it's these two and then it's mbl
did we have anyone else alexander
grishik yeah he wasn't in this one
though was he
no he wasn't in this one but he was in
the yeah so
we'll will sort of the coaches and
seconds and the players have
kept an eye on this tournament it's only
a month until the candidates
absolutely i mean one thing that you can
say about the candidates is that
napomniachi will actually be playing
with the white pieces
against aneesh giri so you know it's
very
kind of courageous but at the same time
quite a practical approach from
gary just to go you know what let's see
what you got against my night off
let's take you into my the sharpest line
that there is
and see what you have and uh why not and
maybe forces
nepo to sort of bring his best because
he also wants to win this tournament of
course
and it's huge money and it's huge
prestige and
you know qualifying for the tour final
do you think nepo has used his
best response i think uh all these top
players
um they normally have kind of a
three-tiered opening repertoire
usually you have ideas in mind in
must-win situations
you save openings your most aggressive
openings for those must-win situations
sometimes you'll have an opening where
okay it's just
it's kind of uh geared towards aiming
for the draw safety first
and you'll also have an opening that you
just used just to get a position
and uh kind of chance for both sides and
then you play this to me seems like the
weapon you'd use in a must-win situation
so napoli actually maybe he's given away
one of his secrets here
but um yeah maybe he's maybe he's got a
bag of tricks maybe he's full of these
kind of must-win
ideas and um okay meanwhile we do see
the offer of a trade of queens
and uh napoleon actually says yes you
can trade the queens but on my terms
and that's very instructive um lots of
players i found
well and myself when i was young when i
was first learning chess
if i see the opportunity to trade i
would just go for it i wouldn't think
about
kind of who gains time in that process
in that transition
here napoleon actually steps the knight
back because if the queens
are traded in the middle of the board
white will recapture with the knights
and white
improves his piece white gains time with
that uh transition
so a very nice idea there by napole on
the last move
i'm not saying it's the best move but it
would benefit white now
at least slightly if any giri plays
queen takes queen
and he does it yes uh i mean i've been
very impressed by anish
i'm impressed by his bravery element
press by his preparation and all the new
ideas that he's brought to
the game and i do quite like
akshay's a comment where he says why is
tao playing under the name of anish giri
hal of course is a former world champion
who was famed for his crazy absolutely
insane
attacking abilities wait so tal died in
92 anishigiri was born in 94 do you
think anish is tal reborn
well i i think you have some theorists
start now
yeah maybe um okay
meanwhile we're talking about how
impressed we are by anish um i was
impressed by his
last move or his last couple of moves um
if we quickly bring up the analysis
board we can see in this position
um white uh did retreat the night
guarding the queen i thought anishigiri
wouldn't take this queen i thought you
wait a bit longer
you try and force white to capture on
your terms but nope anish gary took
these off and now the key move
um this bishop which is kind of under
fire from the white knight now drops
itself back to where it came from
its start square evicting this white
rook and now the white rook no longer
targets this bishop so black can finally
castle and black is happy
successful opening i think by any
shakira yeah totally successful and with
a
with a relatively uh unusual line as
well
he didn't even have to play his main
ideas in the opening
just uh something else and uh let's
count the material the material
is still it's level it's level material
white does have three isolated pawns
however whereas black only has two
isolated pawns by isolated pawns we mean
pawns with no other pawns uh next to
them essentially so white has
two isolated points on that left side
and one in the center long term
you want to have as few of those guys as
possible because they can become
targets for the opponent's pieces yeah
that's why i slightly prefer black
although
in general it should be a relatively
balanced position
so while we're waiting for to respond
let's take a question from
me madrin al-hadri who says what does
someone have to do
to reach 1500 elo if they are already
rated
1000 good question
i mean great question there i mean the
first thing i would do is
i would just play as much as possible
online for example you can play on
chess24.com you can find opponents
around the same level as yourself
um the thing after that though is always
to analyze those games try and look
where you went wrong either with a
friend
or even talk to your opponent about it
discuss where things
uh where the critical moments were um if
not
yeah find a friend find a coach maybe as
well as playing
puzzles i think are great they train you
as in our puzzle of the day earlier that
ginger gm showed they train you to look
for these checks and captures
they improve your intuition the more you
look at these things the better your
calculation will become your
visualization
if you start to see maybe two moves
ahead three moves ahead occasionally
then
that will improve your rating um no end
and uh
yeah when i was young english
grandmaster nigel short he told me
tactics are 90 of chess and um
that's right no matter how good your
strategy is in the end to win games you
have to find that final breakthrough
so working on puzzles and things like
that i think we'll just get that extra
total
totally and uh well luckily our quiz of
the day is an amazing prize it's a
monster bundle and it will be everything
to solve
anyone's uh needs in chess it's like a
one-year premium membership chess 24
anish geary's a chessable sicilian
course
and sorry night of course then it's a
chessable pro membership
and then a play magnus one year
membership you know those are the
perfect tools
i actually want to whoever wins this
let's let's uh
get that person to give his rating or
her rating on chess 24
and then let's check it a year from now
yeah
because i bet that person's just going
to skyrocket yeah absolutely
you know i mean these are tremendous
resources available to you i know
and chassis ball and chest 24 they have
lots and lots of videos that you can
watch
to improve uh chess 24 has the tactic
trainers as does the
play magnus trainer and uh you know it
also is the perfect learning tool what
can i say
yeah definitely now we were actually
talking about it earlier today david
yeah when was the last time
you had like a really big leap in chess
that you
did made lots of progress because that
must be a long time ago
being on the top level now for me it was
too long ago
um i guess the kind of last huge leap i
made was just after i left university
um so this was going back a few years it
was in 2014 i barely played for four
years
and then i came back my next few
tournaments were
well i don't want to say a huge success
but i did quite well yeah and i jumped
up from maybe the low 2600s
to 2700 wow yeah so i entered the elite
i got to top 30 in the world
that's a huge sleep yep it was hugely
unfortunately from there it's been a bit
up and down and up and down
well how about you you banker i mean
being on that top level
it must be just tiny steps you take all
the time and maybe
steps back as well yeah i mean i kind of
suffered a little bit from the
the yo-yo effect you know i reached a
certain level very very quickly
and then i started needing to take these
uh tiny steps and
uh it was really annoying because i kind
of i was breaking
20 well i was kind of getting close to
2500
at least on some tournaments that i had
played and then i had like
three amazing tournaments and then three
bad tournaments and took me back to
square one and i was like
so i mean since then i've kind of
suffered a little bit from that you know
i just
three steps forward three steps back and
i'm just like okay come on you know i've
got to make that leap sometimes
well how about this game then david yeah
talking of making leaps black knight
black's knight did make a leap into the
white half of the board into the white
position
attacking one of white's bishops and
therefore that bishop stepped
into the center of the board and
actually white's bishops now they mirror
anish geary's bishops in the last game
in the previous game
this time it's an end game though or
pretty much an endgame
i do expect anishkiri's first goal to be
eliminating one of those two white
bishops because
we do talk about the bishop pair bishops
tend to be very powerful when they're
both uh pawns on both sides of the board
especially in endgames so if anish giri
for example can trade his knight for one
of the bishops
or even trade the two dart square
bishops off so his own dark square
bishop for white star square bishop
then i think anish should be happy the
game should just be balanced
and yeah i think white though he has
less risk right now if he can maintain
the bishops
long term he should be in the ascendancy
but is it is there winning chances for
both still yeah there's
plenty of life left um it's not anywhere
near a draw right now
um it's just i think especially if a
pair of bishops come off if black can
make that trade then it's just chances
for both sides
um it will come down to who's maybe more
creative or
more aggressive who can play on the
front foot in the end game i mean
that white pawn is very far advanced yes
the black you know only one square
behind it though but
yeah um is that maybe the aim here to
get that queen
yep i think long long term um it's about
creating past pawns simply if we bring
up the analysis board we can see
um as um as kaia mentions white does
have this very far advanced pawn
um this very nice pawn but it has
created some weaknesses because
this pawn although it's far advanced it
can no longer protect the squares behind
it
and um i mean the squares behind it all
to the side of it and
um the square in front of it that's the
key one to blockade and that's why
anishiri
does blockade this pawn he also does
manage to get these bishops off
now it's bishop versus knight um this is
bobby fisher's favorite assortment the
light squared bishop against the knight
and uh the pulmonary plays a bit of a
mysterious move bringing his rook up to
this square
um getting attacked um this pawn was a
target on a light square so now it's on
a dark square and it's going to be doing
all the right things here
it should be balanced um yeah this pawn
somehow i i kind of want to put it back
where it came from because it does
block this bishop and the bishop tied
down
so usually white would have a small
advantage here i think it's just
completely
level and do you approve of uh
napomniachi's last move which is like
centralizing the rook
because i mean let's face it that wasn't
the most
mobile square for the rook i'm trying to
be as diplomatic as i can be
and uh he has conceded an open line
especially when he's when the rook is
looking at a pawn that is
to be frank protected by a knight yeah i
mean i
i'm a big baffled yep baffled is a good
word for it
um meanwhile napoli actually pushes a
pawn up one square but it does feel like
anishieri he's improved his position
enormously um the black rook has found
an open line
um i think the next thing for black to
do is to start bringing the king
maybe even bring the king to the center
try and trap this white rook yeah in the
middle of the board
um yeah it looks like anishigiri he
solved all of his problems white isn't
in trouble because there are no targets
in white's position
black's night okay you called it david
the king is making its bid for freedom
it's going to go into the center and
try to defend the pawn okay but you know
obviously the probably actually put his
rook there for a reason
and uh he wants to attack the pawn so he
therefore okay i was
i was going to say retreat the bishop
but now okay he's doing something else
he is caging the king in he's saying
nope
you want to come in with a king that's
not possible okay
we are i mean anish must be confident
with his position because he's playing
so quickly it's rare to see him play
this quickly
and he just wants to eliminate this
white rook so that the black king has a
path to the center
um would you take this rook off the
board ivanka no i wouldn't i would uh
think about would you dance around with
the rook
maybe i would sound out whether anisha
is happy with a draw
you know just to see just to see we
could see a draw for example if the
rooks challenge each other but if anish
giri wants to play for a win then he
might use
his other rook um now to challenge for
the open line black now has two active
rooks
um whereas white has one kind of
strangely placed rook
um so yeah still chances for both sides
but
logical play as well from the players
neither side giving
ground at this point uh this moment what
would you do david
take the rook yes i would take those
rooks and then i'd bring the white king
towards the center
unfortunately we didn't do a bet for
this because i still i'm still like one
nil down right
no vicki's in the probably actually says
no
no peter says no exactly and
i i do think that your move is going to
be seen though
gary is going to step with his left rook
and just challenge the white rook on an
open line because it's the most natural
move on the board
indeed um yep i expect to see one of the
black rooks challenge for that line now
that the white rook is just occupied
that b
line and still completely
balanced chances and balanced also in
uh the second game in the battle for
third place minus thousand one
the first game in spectacular fashion
the second one
has ended with a draw so if magnus
wins the next one the third one then
actually the first match
will be over they will be done for today
they will keep fighting tomorrow
if it is a draw or a win for wesley then
they will also play that fourth game
yeah and we do have a move we do have a
move and as predicted
um and jimmy does challenge for that
b-line um so
will we see a rook trade it's gonna be
hard for napoli actually to keep
avoiding that
um yeah meanwhile and it's very look at
that uh
air quality it is yeah
he's always on the breakthrough so he's
on the brink under the co2 level
especially
just below 1000 but that tends to climb
as the day goes on as well still
after this game if it is if it does end
in the draw still two more
tension-packed games so um he's going to
be hoping that the co2 levels don't
affect him
meanwhile it is very warm there as well
um i'm surprised i
i mean personally i just can't play when
the when it's that warm
i have to open the windows um yeah no
that's a it's a good idea with the
having good air quality in the room um i
think colder
tends to be better for the concentration
i mean okay so so we have seen a rook
trade
and now napomni actually has moved his
rook from the center to attack the pawn
of course and niece doesn't let napoleon
actually have that pawn and instead
defends it okay but okay what are we
going to see are we going to see the
white king
make a bid for freedom get to the center
but then it gets in the way of its own
rook
yep both kings could dart towards the
center white's rook
and black's rook both kind of strangely
placed right now um they're kind of just
kind of looking at each other kind of
there's a hedge in between it's as if
they're neighbors
but they're looking at each other across
the garden and they're just neither of
them wants to talk to the other one
um but who will give way first who will
yeah back into the house first
and uh run away from that tension could
you be
kind of like play on both wings so now
i'm thinking okay since
i do like the idea of running with the
king to the center
okay and i didn't think about this one i
was going to suggest advancing pawns on
the right side of the board
just to kind of take some squares away
from the night
but okay is is this just simply a um
nepo just saying
hey let's simplify i think that's a very
ambitious move by nipponyachi he just
wants to
um kind of improve the scope of the
white bishop
um if we bring up the analysis board we
can see um with
this move actually just before this move
if you look at the white bishop it's not
doing great it's kind of
looking at its own pawn it's looking at
its own pawn down here as well maybe
tied down to the defense of that later
on
so why not trade off this pawn as
napoleon does if there is a trade then
maybe the bishop will take back
and now the black's king will always be
tied down to this guy
this will always be a target later on
and white's bishop it now has the
freedom of the board
i mean even if white wants to capture
with the rook you could imagine this
bishop kind of rerouting itself round to
the longest diagonal possible is
going to control so many squares now
that the position has opened up bishops
love those open positions
napoleachy he does go for this but
meanwhile
i mentioned about trades earlier you
only do it on your own terms giri
ignoring that
he brings the king forward and he's
allowed this trade will he capture back
with the knight
improving his night in the process in
the transition of this capture
uh will he maybe step his king forward
and take this pawn later on that pawn
this pawn is not running away any time
soon it will be captured
i think maybe giri will be tempted to
improve his king first
before getting greedy and restoring
material parity
all right this is a slower game right
right yeah calmer before the storm maybe
yes
who knows it started in dynamic fashion
but both players just equally well
prepared
we actually saw it on the first day of
the semi-finals when the pontiac was
playing carlson
when he got caught in a surprise with
the white pieces he was happy to play
safe
um well napoleon actually looked
surprised by
giri's choice there the black king um
there's
actually a variant of chess called king
of the hill and the whole aim of that
game is to get your king to one of the
four central squares
black's king got there first he won the
game
but this is not king of the hill this is
a standard chess and we did see another
set of
porn trades and um it's not clear who
that favors
but currently the bishop does look more
versatile than that black knight
yeah yeah but the thing is though yes
the bishop the light square bishop is
versatile can
kind of go between the two sides but
there are no
no no pawns to attack in order to do
that you need to bring in the king
um difficult difficult difficult things
and
uh while napoli actually steps forward
with
his own king and uh i don't know i'm not
seeing
that the position is that ambitious
actually for both
both sides no i think especially for
black um black
i mean with his rook yes he's attacking
the bishop right now but once that
bishop retreats the black rook is stuck
defending a pawn
so it's kind of it's doing a defensive
job white's rook
is still awkwardly placed badly placed
but it is at least attacking a
black pawn keeping the black rook tied
down so
the status quo is i mean it's completely
balanced but i would still prefer to be
white
um slightly because you could imagine a
scenario where
i mean black it just gets tied up a bit
and yeah so
right now if i were to be ambitious i
would be advancing with my pawn on the
right
and i would pick up the one um not not
the most corner porn but the the like
the one on the light square i would pick
that up put it two squares forward
and uh okay um okay
he pushes the corner first same idea
different execution um
different order so white's just going to
try and push all his pawns the problem
is
if you end up pushing pawns on that side
it's likely to see a series of trades
and
yeah yes
hey anish giri does not sit still he he
is playing spoiler right
yep he's trying to initiate that pawn
trade
um you're right your anchor it should
just be completely balanced because
um mm-hmm black's pawns on dark squares
it's okay
to defend them yeah that's true but
having said that
the white rook has now made its bid for
freedom
and the black rook is still tied down
because white will simply play check and
win the pawn if the black rook steps
away but okay
this is a really funny move i mean
putting a pawn on a light square i mean
it must require some active calculation
there
yeah committal move by family and he
played it very fast so he must have
um figured out that he couldn't sit
still any longer he doesn't want to be
passive
he needs to go on to the front foot he
needs to start forcing
napoli actually to worry about king
safety and the pontiac's king decides it
has to step back
maybe it's time for anishigori to start
activating his rook
right now the black rook we mentioned it
was passive um it didn't really want to
stay that way for long
and there we go the black rook now has
created a huge threat of dropping down
the board
and attacking the white king check and
attacking the white bishop at the same
time
that double attack would win a piece so
nice move there by anish giri
yeah he actually has to now he's the one
on the defensive
um i really like what nietzsche has done
over the last few moves
yeah can he maintain that initiative
though that he's uh that momentum he's
gained
it's not clear unfortunately there's
still no way of getting to the white
pawns
there is no way there's no entry point
at all
you know the rooks and the bishop are
doing a great job okay so now here
napoleon i guess could simply offer like
tanzan might offer a draw by just
checking checking the black king with
the rook or the pawn
the black king will have to step back i
think checking with the rook would have
been
very dangerous there because black yes
yes yes we've interfered with the
knights
whoops my bad no but the night
uh the black knight was threatening to
jump forward giving check to the white
king forcing the white king onto the
back rank where
it might even get checkmated so that's
why napoli actually decides he cannot
give
any more ground he has to force that
black king back if he can
he gives check with his pawn so now that
pawn structure is completely fixed on
that right side of the board
um okay anish giri he plays king of the
hill again he centralizes his king
the black king has been looking very
good
this whole game and now white tries to
do the same
white's king not as active as blacks but
occupying the center and
anishigiri it feels like he's trying to
win this one
he's the one making things happen over
the last few moves that black knight now
is attacking a white pawn
an undefended white pawn on that right
side of the board how
will napoleon actually guard against
that um a few options i see but
he does have to be a bit sneaky here you
don't really want to go passive you
can't defend it with your king you don't
want to go passive with your rook
defending a pawn either
rooks are the worst defenders um
i think hey what other options are there
i can't see any other pieces that can
you can attack
now that knight does capture a pawn but
look white rook now has the choice of
capturing
well it has the opportunity to capture a
pawn it has to capture upon or
yeah yeah right you're right kaya um
i did wonder whether he would try to
shake things up a little bit and try to
capture the other pawn but no
that's uh taking risks i think both
sides now just with one pawn remaining
it shouldn't be enough to win this game
um we should be destined to a draw
um but with pawns on only one side of
the board knights tend to be better
trickier
there i mean as long as napoli actually
doesn't walk into some kind of double
attack some night fork
then it should be a draw simply
um i expect to see a few checks with the
rook
white's king back and forth the black
rook back and forth and
the position repeat itself maybe napoli
actually will offer a trade of rooks
here
whether or not the rooks stay on the
board it shouldn't change the uh the
result
in the end okay what happens if white's
like no no no i'm gonna go for gold i
really want to
okay not anymore the rook has been
offered for trade
and okay if black simply captures that
then the game should really end in a
draw
yeah so the rooks will disappear and now
um any scenario where the two pawns
disappear
is a draw neither side will have enough
material to checkmate so even if white
gives up the bishop for the black pawn
or even if black gives up the knight for
the white pawn the game should be a draw
um
i'm hoping we see king versus king at
the end to show a real fight
a real battle to the death but anish
giri he's just trying to work out now
how to give up the black knight for
white's remaining porn
um the only way to win this game for
either side is to make a new queen with
a pawn
that's why it's all about getting rid of
the pawns you don't care about the
pieces
as much there we go the knight gives
check
the knight threatens to take that pawn
um
napoli actually does maintain his pawn
for now so black's pawn is about to drop
uh white's pawn is surviving so honey he
needs to find a path
to get to that porn um how's he gonna do
that ivanka
well he's attacked the bishop which is a
very smart move so but the bishop will
just move
okay now now now definitely now he can
just simply move his okay that that's a
fantastic square
and uh now after king takes okay okay
we do see a king of pornhun game but the
key is it's a corner pawn so black's
king will box in the white king white's
king is actually trapped on that corner
now
white's king is trapped in front of its
own pawn and there's no way to make a
queen
we'll see stalemate white can't make a
move ah
so we finally have a stalemate yay
exciting all right the second game is a
draw yanaponyachi
saying like okay this is okay we have
another draw in the final
between anish giri and the ponyachi the
third game will be coming up
in about 15 minutes and this one david
uh it wasn't as spectacular as the first
one
no far less spectacular but equally well
played neither side made any mistakes in
that room in that game
uh really no no big blunders um no real
inaccuracies either it was just great
opening preparation especially from
anishiri
he equalized the game and never let it
slip and i think it was just this
position
for me the star move was this one um
black now and hq moving the bishop that
is under fire from the knight
retreating it to kick away white's most
active piece the bishop dropped back
attacking this rook and when the rook
did retreat anishigiri got his king to
safety
as soon as that happened it signaled
that black was fine he
fought on an equal footing for the rest
of the game and the next key point came
in this position
when facing the two bishops he traded
one of them off
he offered this trade of bishops and as
we saw once white was
white had to part with the bishop pair
the game fizzled out towards the draw
it's an intense final anish geary and
jana pomnyacci still tied
after two games can someone win the next
one coming up in about 14 minutes
[Music]
we have launched the magnus carlson
celebrity charity chess challenge
and our second celebrity is the
fantastic the academy
award award winner and director cuba
gooding jr and we're so
excited to have you here cuba welcome
oh thank you guys thanks for having me
i'm very excited
i'm nervous i'm nervous
well i i can imagine and i mean you must
be invited to so many
different shows and and things uh being
on a chess show
is this a first for you it's the very
first it's
absolutely very first and i've been
spending all morning trying to reduce
his age to
two yeah you get him down
two i think i can beat him yeah magnus
crossley was fantastic even at 10 years
old and
i just want to ask you cube i'm so
curious about this because in hollywood
i mean on
on movie sets there must be a lot of
waiting
all the time and i'm wondering do you
sometimes then see like chess boards and
actors and directors playing playing
chess to get
just the time to pass all the time all
the time
and i i only just recently started
playing i did a film
called life of a king about the true
story of this high school who
ma in the inner city in los angeles who
make it to the championships
and um they were literally taught by a
janitor who was an ex-convict
and uh it enabled me to learn
certain moves but never really i still
didn't really get into it until i
got this um until i got this uh magnus
app and now i can't stop stop playing it
for a week now i can't
turn it off i've been late for dinners
and meetings and it's really
ruined my life
do you know any other celebrities that
play chess or you've been trying your
wits against
well there's a lot uh i know that um
tom cruise plays and i know that uh
my friend jack nicholson plays but my
brother omar gooding
has challenged me every thanksgiving for
as long as i can remember i'm going to
be ready this year this this christmas
holiday season i'm going to have to
show them what i've learned so fantastic
oh yeah cuba how would you describe your
chess level at the moment do you have
any goals for this game that you're
about to play
uh just not to get beat too fast you
know
i i've been i've been watching the
lessons
part of the magnus app and um
i i've seen so many different strategies
and then
got a little overwhelmed when they
talked about all the moves that
you can make after the second or third
move it jumps up to like trillions and
quadrillions in the
options so um i'm trying not to think
too much just play
well i can imagine though that both
acting and directing must have some
similarities with chess because
it's all about focusing for a long time
and and memory
of course yeah 100 a lot of times on a
set
your main job is just to answer
questions everybody has a question
what what dress should she wear what
should the furniture look like
what is the lighting that you want what
camera angles do you use
the actors ask how do you want me to do
this and
if you're not decisive and make
decisions even if it's the wrong
decision
if you don't make decisions then
everybody kind of loses their way and
loses focus
so yeah it's a lot like chess when
you're trying to strategize a piece you
have to think
all right if i tell this actor to do
this then that actor is going to do that
and that's the performance i want it's
the same thing with the chess piece
you're waiting
for your opponent to make a move then
you're going to respond to that move and
he's going to respond in that moving
away and the farther you can think into
the you know the future the better you
are so
yeah so i mean definitely actually
there's a lot of
similarities so do you think both actors
and
and directors and making movies um also
can sort of learn something
from the chess players or it would be a
good thing for people in your
business to to practice chess
absolutely it's funny too because if you
think of what we do we're in the
business of
make believe which is you know
magic sleight of hand disbelief and
that's all that chess
is once you can get your opponent to
think you're reacting
a certain way but it's completely
different than what they thought you win
so yeah i see the similarity there the
connecting
tissue there 100 yeah all right well
it's getting closer ivanka
yes can you tell us the rules on how
this works the magnus crossing celebrity
charity chess challenge
the celebrity will play against magnus
age 10 in the play magnus app
sounds easy but you have to remember
magnus h10 was a master of tricks
the celebrity will get two minutes on
the clock and the goal
of course is to beat magnus carlsen now
if this doesn't happen
the next goal is to last for as many
moves as possible
and the reason it's two minutes is
because in 2014
magnus carlsen himself he was then 23 he
played bill gates and bill gates
lasted nine moves and our first
celebrity here
on this challenge was sal khan he lasted
13 moves so cuba what is your goal
well it'd be great to get to two no 13
might be good
that's my lucky number 13. let's see if
we can get there 14 even
let's go all right well are you ready
i'm ready
so here it is the magnus carlson
celebrity charity chess challenge
[Music]
all right cooper's gonna start with the
white pieces david you're gonna
commentate
that's right so here we go about to
start
cuba okay he opens with this kingsporn
he's looking focused already
um he's occupying the center solid stuff
he has just lost a pawn in the middle of
the board
he will he will recompose himself though
he i mean still in the balance black
there very surprising move giving the
pawn back
he's yeah he's fighting cuba looks like
a decent position for white
he needs to guard against the threat
though to an important pawn
very focused he's very focused and he's
been playing fast that's a good thing
um okay he looks like he's about to move
his queen but where does he want to move
it to
uh he needs to bring his queen out maybe
attack the black knight in the center of
the board
okay he's deciding what to do now he's
slowed down a bit
he has moved to pawn
[Music]
we did make a hit oh well we did hear
him make a sound there he realizes that
he has
lost an important pawn
why is queen under attack rook under
attack as well
looking difficult okay he finds a great
move
counter-attacking against black's bishop
white's queen
under threat he does see it
i mean rude
yeah cuba has walked into a knight fork
so he has just lost his queen
but he's not out of this game he has to
keep playing quickly um remember it's
about how long he can last as well
um not just the position on the board
magnus 10
is a trickster he has managed to find
some nice tricks
but he's playing fast now yeah he's
playing fast he needs to speed up only a
few seconds left now
[Music]
okay he's lost his rook on this in the
corner of the board yeah this is intense
time to develop your pieces
move those pieces out cuba bring out
your bishop bring out your knight okay
he pushes the ball
it's a good move he's surviving and he's
still playing quickly
not looking too happy here not looking
too happy but okay
he's he's playing fast and that's the
most important thing he has lost his
queen he has lost a rook but
it's not game over yet okay he moves his
king away he saw that threat instantly
i think we've lasted longer than 13
moves so i think this is good news
um okay yes the move is king okay he's
the time has run out magnus wins how
many moves did he last
that's the big question all right we're
gonna see how many moves if you press
continue koopa then we're going to see
how many moves you lasted
we think it's good news actually yes
is it 16 moves 60 moves congratulations
you're on top of the table
i feel like a warrior in heaven
look i just got beat by a 10 year old
boy
the more booze than anybody else
that's fantastic so david here was
commentating on the game do you want to
sort of hear his verdict cuba
i i i heard that's the last little bit
but i didn't hear before that what'd you
say dave no i was i was impressed you
were playing quickly you were playing
all the sensible moves but magnus
is a trickster and he did actually we
heard you when he made that night check
attacking your king and queen at the
same time that was sneaky right
i couldn't believe it i didn't see it
even coming when he stole my night i was
like what the hell
the other celebrity they lost this is
ella
yeah yeah so you lasted longer than
salcon
bill gates i'm so excited it's just so
exciting that i lasted 16 months out of
coffee
i don't know what else to say i i you
know i'd like to thank i'd like to thank
my family
for losing 16 i'd like to thank ella who
i'm doing the charity forum is type one
has
type one diabetes come on and now let's
say smile for the people
come say smile this is ella yes
come here
is this a future chess player or even a
current chess player
she was teaching me moves yesterday i
would only made it to 15 if it wasn't
fella
fantastic so she didn't play it was
three
like chris wow wow well
cuba you mentioned it uh it is the
magnus carlsen
charity uh challenge so the meltdown to
champions chester is donating five
thousand dollars to your charity and
what is that
like we were saying yeah it's the
diabetes research institute for
um finding a cure for type 1 diabetes
and um
yeah you know any any little bit helps
and one day we'll
eradicate this condition completely so
here we are
playing chess for cost a good cause
fantastic
yeah and you are on top of or our
celebrity
challenge uh list so what's going to be
your next chess goal then uh to beat him
i'd like to beat him i don't care how
old he is i'll get him in the crib
if i got to oh i'll take the pacifier
out of his mouth
and keep playing till they lose
fantastic
cuba getting jr coming for magnus
carlson no doubt
it was so much fun having you with us
thank you so much cuba
absolutely no this is fun i lost my
voice yelling
at the game that's what chess will do
you yeah you did well
fantastic thank you so much anytime
anytime guys thank you that was fun bye
a great performance bye cuba gooding jr
he's on top of the table two celebrities
have done the magnus carlsen celebrity
charity chess challenge
16 moves for cuba gooding jr 13 moves
for sal khan and
yeah that's what chess will do to you
losing your voice david
yeah losing your voice and occasionally
losing to the world champion
even at age 10 but he put up a good
fight and uh i was exp
i was impressed by his reaction time he
saw the checks coming and
um okay there were a couple of sneaky
moves that he did miss but
in general with a few more goes i think
he can put up a fight
in future and we're going to have more
celebrities throughout the entire season
of multiple champions chester so
what tips should the next sort of
celebrities take with them jamaica
well you've got to play fast this is all
about the mountain moves and
also i'd recommend just develop all your
pieces get your king to safety
and just carry on developing and you
can't go wrong
all right this is so much fun the mines
carlson celebrity charity chess
challenge we're also having a lot of fun
in the final of the magnus carlson
invitational
let's take a look at the standings after
two games they have played
two draws in each geary and yonder so if
anyone can win one of those two last
games
we will have a winner of the first match
magnus carlsen and wesley so are playing
for
the third place magnus with a
spectacular win in the first game they
are now currently sitting there
playing the third game i hear rumors
magnus is still
being very creative today david yeah he
he definitely has been using i mean
all of those remaining creative juices
that he wasn't able to show
in those semi-finals and despite the
fact that
it is a third place play-off he has been
playing some incredible chess
he has not been lacking motivation or
anything magnus carson
uh looking back to his best and the
third game between these two anish geary
starting in a few seconds and it wasn't
the first game where anish
did have those white pieces that we did
have quite a spectacular game yamanaka
so what do you expect from this one
well you know i expect more of the same
from anish you know perhaps he's not
going to choose that specific opening
because i do think napolita will have
been on the phone to his seconds and
said well you know what should i play
but you know i'm expecting another
little tricky sideline
and we do not see a repeat of that
opening from the first game
anishigiri as ivanka predicted he's done
something differently here we see
the sicilian defense again but a
slightly different variation of the
sicilian
no more najdorf no more c3 sicilian this
is the taiman of sicilian
and here we do see okay still very quick
play from both sides
and that is quite a rare move on the
last turn white plays knight takes
knight
um offering that trade usually white
delays that slightly
you keep your opponent guessing and only
later trade nights off the board but
this time anichigiri
um rushing ahead and we have seen a
trader pawns a trade of knights as well
and anishigiri as well leaning forward
after that last move
by anna pogliacci may be surprised i
think i mean
black had three choices there you could
have captured that white knight with two
different pawns or you could capture it
with the queen
i think normal is to capture with the
pawn towards the center to control more
central squares
the pommy actually right now is only
playing with his queen the black queen
has
i mean she's just left the rest of her
army behind at home
asleep and anishigiri is going to be
trying to punish that
um risky played by napoleon at this
early stage but clearly he must have an
idea in mind he must have studied this
before
how will anish giri react and get his
pieces into the game that's the
priority now get your king castled it's
an open sicilian that means there will
be open lines there will be attacks
and it's all about speed of activity
speed of getting those pieces developed
well um castling wise this does look
like the first game
because and he still only has his queen
on that side and only has his bishop on
other way around on the other side uh do
you think we'll have alongside castle
here as well you might be
uh yeah you might get your wish kaya um
and ishiguri
the reason he's paused now for thought
is he's just weighing up which side the
white king wants to go to
we did see in the first game white's
king did go across to that queen side to
that left side of the board
and um it paid off he got a great
position okay this time with his last
move he
is pretty much declaring that he is
ready now to castle the king to the
right so
sorry kaya you're not going to get your
wish but i'm still promising though
um i mean look at black's position all
of the pieces at home apart from the
queen
the pontiac he's breaking all the rules
here he's breaking all the kind of
conventions that we're told we're taught
when we're young
and he's gary he's going to try and get
his king to safety and punish
that yeah that concept yeah no
absolutely i did
i was desperately trying to figure out
because it did remind me of the game
that they played against each other
in the preliminary section and there
there was a knight takes
night but we actually saw a pawn that
takes night
so here napoli actually has changed the
goal post he's doing something
completely different
and uh you know look at these two they
are playing
such fire on the board stuff you know
and
it's very appropriate because it kind of
links in really nicely with our quiz of
the day you know we are asking everyone
what is your favorite chess game and we
personally
love it don't we david when we have such
spectacular aggressive chess and uh
well we certainly have had some
interesting answers
toretto he said that one of his favorite
games was
gm shangri-lu against richard bethune
and he particularly liked the move queen
to e7
and well before we take all of the other
answers
let's have a look at the game um yep the
game we have seen
a couple of developments white did push
a pawn forward in order to open up
the light squared bishop to attack uh
black's queen the black queen has had to
step back
we might see a trade of bishops right
now still looking promising for niche
gary he's got a bit more
a bit more space space being the theme
of the tournament white having a nicely
advanced central pawn but if we do see
that trade the bishop's leaving the
board then at least napoleonic
he won't worry about his pieces getting
cramped it's in the balance i slightly
prefer white
but the pontiac has a lot to play for
himself
yeah no i mean i really like this kind
of reaction you know his queen was
attacked and he
simply retreated it and is also
attacking a pawn and talking about
attacking pawns
going back to our question of the day
because i do have to
show you the answers because people have
had such amazing choices
ripples says that his favorite chess
game is vichy annan's immortal game
against
levon aronian one of the classics that's
a great game too
in the slov um fishy and using his
bishops
giving up a queen and that just that
checkmating pattern with the two bishops
yeah great choice there yeah and uh then
finally the
ep sorry epistement oh this is a bit of
a mouthful
that's the one epistemic watchtower he
says his
favorite chess game is number six of the
world championship match between fisher
and spassky
nicknamed the applause especially the
move e4
and queen to f4 and uh yeah another
great
choice you know bobby fischer really
played some fantastic chess
yeah i mean we're talking about favorite
chess game but that's probably one of my
favorite matches one of the main
i mean most historic matches um that
there's ever been in chess
yeah fischer against baskey 1972. yeah
and if you want to enter
our question of the day you can do this
by tweeting us
using the hashtag chesschamps and uh of
course
we really appreciate we do really like
them we love
your pictures and the prize i have to
read out the bomber prize because
we've never had such a such a long list
of prizes just for one winner
well winner will get anish geary
sicilian night of chessable course
one year chessable pro membership
one-year chess 24 premium membership
and if that is not enough one year
magnus trainer membership yeah this is
all comes courtesy of
opera and uh yeah interestingly enough
we've had a few
clever responses all saying that they
really enjoyed the opera game
played by uh paul morphy against
duke von brunson yeah dude yeah yeah
from western yep it's a legendary game
actually kaya is there yeah yeah so i
have to check that out what year was
that your anchor
18 18 something 1856 or something i
think a long time ago i have to say that
that name
paul morphy it keeps uh just everyone's
talking about him
even if it's super long ago since he was
great and i know he had a very short
career right
yes you know it didn't go too well for
him
personally i guess no and in the end he
descended into madness
so i mean but in fact uh talking about
world champions
uh bobby fischer really loved uh paul
morphy's games he thought you know he
was way ahead of his time
and was a big big fan yeah
um i've been reading a lot about paul
morphy recently
and how he insisted in some of his
matches that
his opponents had to play certain
openings just so he could show off how
attacking and
spectacular his style i didn't know that
uh yeah
but yeah either way he was a genius was
that against his chart his uh school
friend
on a college friend i'm not sure who was
against but i just read that it was a
rule that if anyone wanted to challenge
him that was the
they had two times well he would open
with his kingsport they had to open at
least half of their games with their
kingspawn as well
yeah i do have to say i do like love the
story behind the opera game like he
actually genuinely thought that he was
going to
enjoy some opera that his rich friends
had invited him to watch them he was
like i love
opera we're going to be on a box and
they said
yes yes we're going to watch opera but
we're going to play a game during the
opera and paul morphy was like
he didn't like that right yeah and and
what's he even worse
was while the other two had a view to
the action on the stage
he had his back towards the thing so
legend is that he kind of thought well i
have to just finish this game off super
quickly and punish them just because i
just want to enjoy the the stage well
that that is a brilliant mind to be able
to
to do that it's a multi-task indeed and
that
game the opera game very spectacular and
actually anish giri has finally castled
and
i thought he was about to go through
your favorite move kaya castling on that
left side but no
he castles on the king side so we do
definitely have a different game than
the first one
yes but there are still many imbalances
and
lots to play for uh both sides have um
strong points of their position and also
weaknesses if we bring up the analysis
board we can see
the current position white is ahead in
development white's king is nicely safe
white's queen is out bishop out all
these guys perfectly placed
also if black is a bit careless and
allows white's knight to the center of
the board
white's knight will become dominant
aiming into a potential outpost
here if we can kick this bishop back
um if the black king castles for example
if we kick the bishop back maybe there's
also another square the knight can jump
to attacking the queen attacking the
pawn
um i mean i'm not sure there's just too
many tempting moves with the knight
maybe you want to go this way
um this is a real octo knight in the
middle of the board yeah maybe you even
sacrifice it this
maybe my bishop my bishop can go all the
way to the edge
maybe this way and a trap if i like her
checkmates and this
i mean this is a real i mean it's a real
possibility if the white knight gets to
the center of the board and is able to
start joining the attack the black king
would be trapped here so i think in
diana ponechi he has to do something
okay he has to do something about this
white knight trying to jump into the
center
maybe playing on autopilot bringing his
knight to the middle which i
would uh be very tempted to play as
black maybe it's a mistake because the
knight does jump into the center of the
board
maybe it's time to eliminate this guy
otherwise it's just becoming
too strong um the only downside is that
maybe the white bishop is going to start
was going to say
that he diagonally stopping the black
king from castling later on done it he's
done it but you know
that move had some serious drawbacks and
like you said
it's just gifting white all the dark
squares here you go
have them and uh well do you see any
plan of neutralizing um
i think the only thing is um giving
white the dark squares
but trying to fight for the light
squares maybe if the bishop joins this
diagonal you can
pin it later on you i mean it's still
ugly for black but you maybe you plant
your knight on a light square you just
hope that the dark squares
um aren't enough on their own to give
white a winning advantage
um yep there the computer did suggest as
we see below the board the computer did
suggest
this move taking back with the queen you
don't want to double your own pawns look
how ugly this pawn structure would be
um especially these two pawns would be
eternal weaknesses that's why the
computer
did suggest taking with the queen and it
happened um
the knight developed itself and now
again look at that stock fish
the computer does think that one white
move is much better than all of the
others
bringing this bishop to a fantastic
diagonal
eyeing up the black knight and stopping
black from castling the black king is
stuck
having to defend um it's horsey
in the middle of the wood and that is a
bit of a no-brainer david
um i mean it's the most natural move on
the board
black wants to castle and you're like no
of course not and
i'm fully expecting a niche to play that
move
and again the question is really really
very unpleasant
for for black how is he going to handle
that i wasn't entirely convinced by the
lines that you showed
for black for black that is i mean and
uh
anisha's played it but i mean i do agree
that that is the best chance you know
the rook
should line up against the bishop and uh
obviously the queen
will now move away or perhaps the bishop
will be reinforced
but uh certainly once again
jana pomneyacci has gotten into trouble
with the back pieces
yeah anish really playing on the front
foot
not being afraid to go forward to attack
to develop his pieces and
it's all looking good for him but he did
miss a golden opportunity in the first
game
in that queen end game uh and okay he's
going to be hoping that he can keep
control now the only thing for any
theory is the clock situation as well
if you look at the times and it should
be nine and a half minutes you end up on
actually 13 and a half minutes
so four minute deficit when it's still
very tense um white's position is good
but you still need to get your rooks
into the game you still need to get at
that black king somehow
doing the right thing playing a quick
move supporting his bishop
look how i mean that white bishop is
just so strong
yeah it's it's a beautiful thing as oh
the i was going to say
how the australians doing that's a beaut
i don't know why that came in
exactly because i was thinking about
that move because it kind of releases
the queen to go off on some adventures
on the right side of the board
just to kind of threaten some horns and
try to penetrate into the position
it's just such a lovely lovely
thing that anish can do play left side
right side
it's a dream um it's a dream but it's
not game over
black is able to castle and that was the
key um
um although i liked his pawn push maybe
there were other ways to try and stop
black from castling
i forgot about that that elementary
point
never forget your opponent can castle um
the problem actually did that in the
last game i think it was already
past move 20 that he cancelled now again
castling late the pontiac
on move 17. but aneesh gary he's
ignoring that right side of the board
he's only playing on the left flank
right now he's trying to open lines for
his rooks
and that's the next step he's just he's
kind of secured a
phenomenal piece that white bishop
nicely anchored
um next is to get the rooks into the
game and uh anishi is doing that by
opening lines
makes sense um how will napoli actually
react to that first you have to
um do something about the black knight
the black knight
not under threat at the moment because
the white bishop is pinned
for example in this car in the past
position white could not capture this
knight
because suddenly the queen would drop
behind it
but in the current position napoliti
sooner or later he will have to deal
with this knight
because if he plays slowly if he pushes
a pawn for example
white's queen will suddenly find a
decent square and
not only is this knight attacked but the
rook behind it might also be a factor
that's why i expect after white spawn
push uh black
to try and gain some time maybe jump
forward with the knight attack this
queen first
when the queen moves i'm not sure where
it will go but
when the queen moves just move your rook
so everything out of the eyeline of this
bishop essentially
you cannot let this bishop continue
pinning and winning
along this diagonal so now the bishop
still good but hitting
thin air um white meanwhile will try to
open up his own rook
to get into the game yeah and this would
be quite promising furnished gary but
not the end of the world for napoli
actually at least and
that's the key now to survive for nepo
yeah i mean i really do
like um this idea of just domination and
you can see
omni actually is following your advice
just reinforcing that night stepping out
of the way of the pin
and uh yeah you're saying it so
brilliantly uh david that you have a fan
frank francesco
pacerli says wish of the week david as a
chess
teacher
i still need to improve myself at the
teaching
um yeah maybe one day your wish will
come through
yeah what is the most you know we have
the funny thing with the with our
question of the day is that you have
different elements of it you can have
your favorite game that you've witnessed
your favorite game
that you've studied your favorite game
by your favorite player
i mean but what's your kind of like your
funniest game that you've ever seen
oh funniest game that i've ever seen
wasn't it didn't we have a lot of laughs
in one game this tournament um maybe it
was that
the double bong clown came with magnus
oh yeah hey karen like
ah that was it yes mixed feelings about
that one it was funny but
really chess okay funny
chess games i don't know
that's a really hard question yeah i had
i had a funny kind of experience with
when i was
about 16 or so i was playing for my
chess club
and you know my dad was a super keen
chess enthusiast and we'll be playing
every single night of the week and i
remember my brother was
captaining this team and we were short
one player and it just so happened that
you know we were playing with the first
team
and in the venue we were gonna default
one game
but my brother spotted that there was
someone in our third team playing he had
just lost
really quickly and so my brother was
like please please can you play for us
otherwise we're going to default and uh
he goes i
don't really fancy it i've lost really
quickly my brother's like please please
please and so he turned he's like okay
fine and he turns up and he plays his
game and he
wins he wins like in like half an hour
against someone super strong
and afterwards like the guy is like oh
my god you played so amazingly did you
see this no
and in the postmortem everything did you
see this and this no
why did you make that move because i
liked it
[Laughter]
and everyone laughed yeah everyone
laughed he was like our hero and after
he won that you know we were like player
of the year that's the good thing about
chess if you understand
you don't necessarily need to see
anything yeah um just use your instincts
yeah trust them now well uh
i i remember a fun game that i i saw
with you david
uh only like a month ago or something
you were at my house playing some
blindfold
chess right yeah uh obviously against
someone
very much lower rated than you he's a
strong chess player though he's our
producer so i'll say nice things
but you were brilliant blindfolded and i
started without a rook
exactly and we do remember this one so
um this player his name is the young
made one move he was very happy about it
and he thought maybe now i tricked the
great david howell
and you just sat over there in the sofa
blindfolded and say
ooh sneaky yeah
dude your blindfold is interesting yeah
it's it's good training apparently well
it's in
insane to watch when you're not a chess
player i have to say that is
just something of the most impressive
stuff that i see
but it's difficult for chess players i
mean it just requires a lot of focus and
that takes training that's
practice it doesn't come naturally trust
me it must be exhausting as well that
you feel very tired afterwards
yeah that was actually quite interesting
and quite funny enough it was my
husband's uh
he's a chess player as well and he said
to me i can play three blindfold games
at once and i'm like really
can you and so i just saw i was like
let's let's play
and uh the first board we're like okay
we can play this move and we were good
second board you know we're good on the
first move by the second move he'd
forgotten
forgotten what he'd played and i was
like you're not that good at
blindfold you know but it's tough it's
tough but okay we've seen some
liquidation
simplification on the board and we also
have a runaway pawn
i mean that is going to be worrying yeah
i mean anish giri he's banking
everything on the attack right now um
i'm very surprised actually by any
shari's decision
but it might pay off um and although the
computer isn't a fan as well we do see
the
the bar in the middle it could still go
either way that does not mean it's a
draw that does not mean it's
uh completely balanced it just means
white's attack
might not work but um black has to be
accurate in order to refute it if we
bring up the analysis board we can see
white right now
has maybe one or two key ideas in the
position
the runaway pawn ivanka mentions is this
one there's pawn darting up the board
and the plan is to open up lines towards
the black king
i'm about to cough sorry
in this position and um plus you've been
talking non-stop for 8 days
yes a lot of talking and wow i was about
to
say
white porn is going to jump up the board
wow yeah i can take over david don't
lose your voice
now david just keep the board up you
talk us through it
yeah there is now fire on the board
because you know
the big threat for white was simply to
advance the pawn
and just force black to make
these weaknesses on the right side of
the board but instead
look at that well napoleon actually has
chosen
just to explode open the position which
is
so high risk you know the traditional
method is that you don't
open lies against your king and uh very
very nicely done
so brave kind of idea is it good though
i'm not so sure that it's uh
a good move uh or a good idea for nepali
actually i think maybe he rushed to
clarify the situation now anishiri
as we so as we see below the board there
he does have a couple of strong moves
the one i was very attracted to at first
it's not what the computer wants to play
but it is to drop the bishop back this
bishop was previously on a decent square
but there's more important things
for it to do drop this bishop back try
and eliminate the best defender
remember knights are king's best friend
eliminate this black knight open up
even more lines towards that black king
however the computer thinks that maybe
first
you can trade a set of pawns um
interesting open up this rook but
maybe primarily to create a weak porn
and just to
play strategically to go for an isolated
pawn uh maybe too many weaknesses in the
black camp
yeah that's a very interesting approach
very logical very cold and calculating i
mean
i must admit i would never have dreamt
of capturing that pawn
for the primary reason that i want to
attack and i don't want to let the black
queen
cross over to the right side so easily
and
okay well anish has gone for your
approach david you guys are channeling
each other
so uh okay so napolita has been forced
to defend that night with his rook
and uh okay now well napomiacci is
threatening to kind of play
queen to the santa and just to kind of
bring everything and threaten some
trades
yep i think it's a bit of a dream right
now for
the pontiac to take the queens off the
board um
normally the defending side wants to
eliminate the queens and the prominently
actually he has to worry about how
strong simply white's bishop is black's
knight just holding things together
right now but it isn't going to be there
long term at the very least
if any giri i mean if everything goes
wrong he can always take the bishop
uh take the night with his bishop and
yeah let things fizzle out so anish giri
he is the one with some margin for error
he's got the leeway how can he attack
black's pawns though black does have two
isolated pawns one in the middle one on
that left side of the board
and i think it's time to start hitting
them maybe bring the rook across one
square attack a pawn
um maybe use your queen to attack that
pawn bring the rook across
you know rook attacks the pawn and then
okay ask
black how are you going to defend that
pawn because uh there's only one move
that i can see
and that is the queen must centralize
herself but where
that's the problem um okay i was going
to say if yeah if you no matter where
you put the queen there will be some
implications this pawn
and this pawn would be target instead
anishikari goes for a completely
different approach
he brings his queen across and he's
trying to use his queen and bishop to
line up against
this pawn um also there was a threat
against the black knight
which has moved will we see a trade of
rooks ivanka will we see
rook takes rook right now no no what do
you think
i think absolutely not i think the rick
is needed in the game to harass black i
think you know you can step the rook
one square to the side and start
attacking the pawns
and also i'm quite aware of the kind of
the situation that i would rather the
peace combination to be a rook and
bishop
as opposed to a queen and bishop working
as the queen of knights
i completely agree um ideologically you
should keep the rooks on the board
however maybe there's kind of a concrete
reason why you might get tempted to
trade the rooks
the only reason anishikiri might get
tempted is now that he can win a pawn he
can bring his queen across attacking a
pawn here
and attacking a pawn here and black
can't defend both of them at the same
time he's going for this
it's on the board david on the board
okay so now how is black going to react
to that
so he has to fight this material loss
with peace activity
that's the only way first question is
will nhgri find this move attacking two
uh
whoops attacking two yes i think so i i
think
why else why else would he have traded
works the other question is he might be
tempted to bring his queen into the
position but now black would just step
his king forward
everything is on light squares for black
these pawns uh the knight as well
they're on light square so they're easy
to protect
and there we see it um the computer's
suggestions just below the board
uh they well stockfish does advocate
this move bringing the queen across it's
not the only move to give an advantage
but it's probably the best one attacking
two undefended pawns
that's the key in every position just
look for look at your opponent's camp
look at what's not protected and once
you know what the targets are it makes
it easier to line up against them
yeah all right and uh anish geary made
his move with
only three minutes and 45 seconds left
on his clock he's
definitely taking his time here yeah but
he didn't make the uh
well the materialistic choice let's say
but i i don't know it's getting close to
an end game materialism
it would make sense in that last uh last
position especially while black's queen
is passive while you have the luxury
of using a move or two to go and grab a
pawn instead anish gives check
black's king is back to safety note how
it's guarding a pawn in the corner there
black only has one undefended pawn
remaining but that's easy to hold with
the black queen so maybe anichigiri
missing a small opportunity there he
still has the advantage
because black's king is more of a target
right now than whites is
black's pawns are slightly weaker than
whites are but
the lower he gets on the clock the more
opportunities he lets slip away
this one could completely uh be flipped
on its head the queen and knight if they
combine
are a great combo and they're a great
duo so
um and also one thing that is not in
gary's favor is his co2 levels they are
rising
they are higher than we saw them
previously uh just in the last round
last round they're around 900 right yeah
right around yeah just under 900 now
they're in the critical
area which is like over 1 000. this is
not good news
and it's something interestingly enough
we saw in the air things masters
that his his his air quality was
consistently really bad and actually it
was his worst tournament by a long shot
yep so co2 levels definitely affecting
gary's play
at least historically will they affect
it in this game
he is attacking a pawn with his queen
right now um
white's queen nicely centralized that's
the perfect square pretty much for
a queen um in queen n games that's i
mean
that's just where you have to put them
they control both sides of the board but
i expected napoli actually to defend
that pawn that is attacked with his own
queen
yeah there's a few ways of doing that
yes to be slightly careful because you
you know
you can't forget that there are two weak
pawns to defend um you can be get a bit
enthusiastic and just think i have to
defend one pawn
and then just overlook the fact that uh
the pawn on the left
needs protection too that's right so um
okay just before napoli actually makes a
move it looks like he's about to make a
move but uh if we bring up the board we
see
one key threat right now you have to
defend this pawn and you have to choose
the right spot and the pogba actually
does that
note how he's guarding this pawn and
this pawn um i was about to say there's
a huge
mistake in the position if the queen
goes the whole way across this would
actually lead to checkmate on the next
move
we love our checkmates i had to point
this out we do we do
we do but it's the kind of easy thing
that you kind of overlook you you're so
obsessed with defending one point in
your position
you completely forget that your opponent
also has some ideas and some moves
and uh you rarely see it on this level
that they play
to to checkmate should we have like a
rule
in this tour that they have to play it
out to checkmate or is that just
rubbing it in it can be it's a nice
kind of uh pretty aesthetically pleasing
checkmate
we can encourage them we could say if
you know just to reward the fans
and to make it clear but sometimes if
it's dead lost and you i mean
the game would go on another 50 moves
then we understand why they would kind
of
yeah save their energy so it's uh it's
difficult but
um for example in game one today carlson
against wesley so carlson was one move
away from checkmate
it wouldn't have hurt wesley to just put
that last move on the board and allow
magnus to show his great idea yeah
because what really happens is that he
pushes the button that says resign yeah
so that's how it ends right
exactly yeah and it's like in the game
um nowadays
normally to resign in an over-the-board
game all you do is stop the clock and
you offer your hand
um in the past i don't know whether they
tipped their king over i think that's
just in the movies
but um they did they did david
it's kind of more like a kid thing to do
you know you kind of knock your king
over yeah
yeah wow and anish giri
i don't understand that last move is he
just gambling
and ishiguri with two minutes left on
his clock he's just given up a pawn
he's offered a pawn sacrifice let's put
it up i don't think it works
okay but let's let's uh put it up on the
board and let's show why it doesn't work
let's get yeah let's get the players
cameras on because
look at napoli at his face he's frowning
he's shocked by that decision white is
pushing a pawn forward here
yes this pawn is currently defended by
the white queen
but once you eliminate the queens once
you take the queens off the board black
can grab a pawn
black would now be a porn up and the
reason anishiri has sacrificed is
because
he wants to push his pawn his new past
pawn down to goal but
i think it's not going to get there
white will push forward the black knight
will step back
potentially guarding the promotion
square of this pawn and if white
continues to step forward then suddenly
black would attack this bishop the
bishop has to retreat um if it goes back
this way
the pawn drops if it goes back the other
way then
suddenly black's other pawn could get
motoring or black can simply
walk his king over and win this white
pawn
note how the black knight does protect
this important square i think anishigiri
has just completely underestimated this
uh or
maybe overestimated his own chances in
this end game if
janna ponicci now plays queen takes
queen and then pawn takes pawn
only black will win okay well actually
napoli actually trusted anish and
instead
took the pawn but i mean that line that
you showed was
super convincing and actually quite
straightforward so it's definitely
something that napoli actually could
have calculated
okay but uh i think what we're going to
see now
is a position where white has a tiny bit
of an
edge because of this outside past pawn
and
napogniachi is just using this whole
idea of working with the queen and
knight
to prevent the pawn from advancing does
anish have anything i don't think so
it's going to be difficult to win this
one
queen and knights together they're just
so tricky right um there will be an
element of danger if white
kind of is a bit too ambitious and steps
forward um
starts running with the pawn then
suddenly you might lose control of some
key squares and the knight will jump in
there might be some night forks
but it is still easier for white to play
at least andish giri
moving his queen up he's offering a
repetition of the position
will we okay this is the second time
we've seen this position if anish giri
moves his queen forward again the game
will end in a draw
uh at the moment he does do this okay
three-fold repetition gary didn't even
try to win that one
um slightly disappointing from gary but
we have seen how good napoleon actually
is in queen anne games
fantastic jana pognyacci is in these end
games and we have
a third draw in the third game in the
final between
anish giri and yana pognati sound a
little bit surprised david
about this result coming so soon yeah
i'm surprised i think geary could have
played on without too much risk
um he could have just maybe pushed a
pawn near his key and created some
breathing space for the white king and
napoli actually the onus was on him to
force the draw we saw how happy he was
how
like instantly he went for that draw at
the end but um yeah giri
i think the reason he uh allowed it is
because he knows
the chance had passed and yeah i think
earlier the bigger chance that gary
missed
wasn't in the final position which
should have been a draw with best play
anyway
it was earlier on in the game we saw him
go on the attack and continue the attack
in this position as white by trading a
set of pawns and now
bringing the white queen across trying
to attack the black king
and after black's knight under fire from
the white bishop and rook
stepped forward we saw trade and i think
this is the biggest chance that gary
missed in the whole game
the clearest cut opportunity at least
instead of giving a check with his
bishop
which led to the game continuation he
could have just sidestepped
with his queen attacking a pawn here and
attacking pawn here he would have gone
up a pawn
so pretty much the same as the game
situation but with an extra pawn for
white
and i think gary would have been
destined to win this game
not easy but a missed opportunity
they are still tied janupomniocci and
anish geary the fourth and final game
in the first match is coming up in 15
minutes
[Music]
there we'll have the white pieces now we
do know that
you know drawing the first match is an
okay result everything will be decided
tomorrow but
do you expect jana palmiacci in great
shape to go all out for the win in that
final one yeah i mean i
certainly think that he's going to try i
mean not necessarily go all out take
extreme risks
but we have seen like a basically that
napomniacci
has been playing aggressively regardless
of the situation
that he's in so i'm expecting him to
come out with something
that puts a niche on edge and we are now
joined
by um simon williams ginger gm hi simon
hi there how are you doing all right
yeah we're both dressed all in black
ivanka's dressed all in black
you're just a bit miserable wasn't it
you were all a bunch of vampires
yeah the angel sitting over here david
yeah well uh what a day simon three
draws so far
in the final but definitely not a dull
final it it feels very intense what's
your take on it
yeah i think it's been a great final i
mean i've been very impressed with the
tactical play that's going on i thought
anish might try to play a bit slow a bit
positional
but he's come out fighting he's come out
with some very
full frontal attacks against yan's king
and he's gone on the offensive i mean
he's been
a little bit unlucky i suppose to get
free draws because he
really should have won one of those
games um and
if he does only draw the match or even
lose the last game
uh he'll be very upset going into
tomorrow
and obviously so much at stake for these
two players i mean the winner taking
home sixty thousand dollars
what would you spend sixty thousand
dollars on simon
um i might get a lighter jacket for next
time
you know i am maybe a lighter t-shirt
maybe maybe take you guys out for a
drink
sounds like a good plan as well yeah so
many things they'll buy you about two
drinks
yes i'll get everyone one drink money's
done and i have to play a game of chess
or something they'd say yeah yeah
let's let's do that in london so we can
have um wow
60 000 drinks instead um but i mean okay
so it's tense in the final
very tense actually but in the battle
for third place
uh i mean that's been super dramatic and
creative especially on
magnus's part i know you followed it a
little bit simon
yeah i mean the first game there was
absolutely phenomenal
display from magnus and it was kind of
like okay the stress is kind of off him
uh yesterday and i think you know you
can see the stress in his play
he's he he's free and he just attacked
wesley and he just checkmated wesley in
about 24 moves
and this just doesn't happen to someone
as strong as wesley so
uh and if magnus could just play like
that more often then
well he would be winning these
tournaments on a regular basis
and i think it is from this game that
the learning point is today so
let's get it simon's learning point
so we get to this position where magnus
has white pieces
and it's a very complex position magnus
has sacrificed a piece earlier he did it
really quickly
and you can see wesley sews king is
stuck on the back there
and it hasn't got much protection around
it all the pawns have been
removed from the board that white queen
is sort of hovering around it just ready
to pounce as well
but where is the killer finish and maybe
people watching this can
already see the killer finish it was a
very nice finish
we've got to use all of our pieces to
attack that king
so the bishop slides in with a cheeky
check there
and the king is now under attack it
can't block the check you can't capture
the bishop there's only one
square the king can try to run to so it
runs to the middle of the board
and now magnus gives one more check now
using his queen and we're just trying to
force that black king
into a situation where it can't escape
and
here well wesley actually resigned here
which is a slight pity because he could
have moved the king up the board
keep running up the board running away
trying to run away do a forest
forest gump there run run run but uh
after this one there's checkmate in one
move the rook
can just get involved and take the pawn
and
they do say the sort of magic number
when you're attacking the king
is to have three pieces attacking and in
this situation
white's got the rook kind of the two
bishops and the queen
so he's got the magic number and that
very nice game for magnus
very nice game from magnus carlsen i
know they're uh
so we won this game they played two
draws they are currently playing the
fourth one
i'm just looking at the bar in my
computer is magnus winning
the fourth one as well david do you have
it um
yes it's looking very good for magnus
all right so he's really
you know striking back today are you
impressed simon
yeah i think just shows you how
pressurized it can be like when you're
playing for third and fourth it's like
okay i can't win it anymore
um third place is still nice let's just
play some chess
and uh without having that kind of
dragging you down you know you can just
play without that pressure and
that's what magnus kind of needs to do
more and i i think even david's
mentioned this as well david
is a fantastic chess player and i think
david mentioned when there's less stress
on him he plays a lot better and maybe
it's something we all have
so yeah just be stress free um and maybe
if we work on our puzzles as well
we won't feel as pressured when we're
playing chess we did have the puzzle
of today simon david loves that game he
said many times
so i'm looking forward to the answer to
this puzzle
yeah so if we go over there it was uh
this was an amazing game
and it was one of the sort of one of the
coolest players around
at the moment daniel duboff and duboff
has been impressing us throughout the
tour with his uh
tau like play you might know of mikhail
tao who is one of the most exciting
chess players in the history of chess
he loves sacrificing his pieces he just
gave his pieces away
to try and hunt his opponent's king down
like some kind of artist
who was just trying to picture paint a
great
piece of art on the board now this
situation what is the black king doing
there again it's doing that forest gump
thing run run run
and it's in the wrong area of the board
it has no defense around it
and it just depends here how white can
try to trap it
so we need to think of ways to create
a net around that king and the move
played here which i hope some
viewers at home some people on twitter
got is
bishop to be free and
if there's not an immediate check that
does something you should be looking for
checks first
if there's not an immediate capture that
does something very good
try to create a fret and this move
does create the threat of now allowing
the queen
to come to that square there with
checkmate now if the bishop is taken
which is obviously something that daniel
must have seen
so let's have a look at that the king
takes the bishop now we have a strong
check the queen comes back to give the
king a check
there's only one square that king can go
to and that is
to the dart square and it's checkmate
can everyone see it
hope so look for the checks give me a
second
okay i'm gonna leave it in your hands
now can you see it
you got it yes i got it i got it you got
it yeah okay so it's the queen right
that's right yeah queen goes over two
squares and delivers
czech mate now there are some other
variations after this bishop b3 move but
that was really the killer move and i
think if anyone at home
found that move you're doing really well
so so well done and uh yeah just a
lovely lovely game that was
is it one of those games that goes into
history we've been talking about you
know the history of chess you like
yeah definitely it's not often that you
see a king run especially
in modern day chess when the king when
the players are actually so much better
than
before and uh of course uh it's
it was such an instructive game and in
an in
an important event david and myself were
both playing there
and we both admired the game yeah yeah i
was very lucky actually i was playing
just the row behind this game and then i
saw a huge crowd gather
there must have been 20 30 people and i
was still playing my game i still
thought okay let's just make a move
quickly and go over and look at this
game and it was
just in the final stages and uh duboff
he was just leaning back he'd seen it
all coming in advance
and he just kind of the way he played
the moves it was as if he knew it was a
masterpiece
uh happening on the board wow oh that
sounds so fantastic to be at over the
board tournaments and
oh the magic of everyone gathering
around boards you missed that simon
yeah definitely yeah it'd be lovely when
we can all meet up again and actually
play on a board and relax afterwards and
uh
yeah you know playing on the computer is
fun but it doesn't nothing beats playing
on a proper
wooden chessboard well um as always we
have to put them on the spot though
ivanka this one is a good one yeah this
one is a good one david
f david simon has a wealth of knowledge
here
so we are asking everyone what is your
favorite chess game
my favorite chess game wow um there was
one game
that i really like and it was between
ivan chuck
and youssef and this was played i think
in about 1990
and it was on the run up to the world
championships and uh
yoshipur sacrificed all of his pieces
and ended up
checkmating at vancouver knocking van
chuck out of that world championships
and
i think the story goes evan chuck was
number two in the world at the time and
a lot of people were saying this guy's
going to be the world champion he's a
real character of vancha
he's being described as a genius and he
lost this game
and he went out into the busy street and
apparently started screaming out there
uh just couldn't handle the loss but it
was it was a very nice game if you get a
chance to
to track it down all right we'll have to
do that good choice
yep all right well let's hope we have
some maybe historical games uh still in
the final thanks so much for joining us
simon
thank you we'll see you tomorrow see ya
all right we're gonna
well it's starting very soon in only a
few minutes but i think we have time for
a couple of uh answers to the question
of today
yeah of course we have tai and kaia
we really love hearing everyone's answer
to the question that we asked what is
your favorite chess game
and we have one from florin savio who
says
courchnoy against kasparov in lucerne
olympia 1982.
it was one of casper's best games and uh
there you can see a picture of the two
and we also liked alex from
fonseca who says his favorite chess game
is the one that he played
against his female cat the true queen's
gambit it's quite good when you you play
your pets
and then we also like ibrahim khalil
hussein who says
he really enjoyed 1960 mikhail tiles
knight sacrificed for almost no
immediate returns to fully activate his
forces
and refused to retreat so he's a big
admirer of
mikhail tower someone that simon
mentioned former world champion he was
famous for just sacrificing
pieces oh we love those games all right
well will we have some sacrifices
in the last game in the finals take a
look at the results
before we head into that final game in
the finals so
they played three draws so far in
ichikiri and yana pomnyacci the winner
of this final game will be the winner of
the first match but of course
they could play a draw and it will be
tied before that second match tomorrow
now
look at that magnus carlsen has finished
his final game against wesley so
winning two games today magnus carlsen
is the clear winner
of the first match in the battle for
third place let's hope we can get a
comment from
magnus after a fantastic day of chess
for him
but it is about mostly about these two
players in the final
inikiri and yana pomniacci heading into
that final
game of the day they are both sitting
quite close to each other inikiri in the
netherlands at 8 o'clock
in the evening we're on a pony actually
even later ten o'clock in the evening
for him
but he has been fantastic in the end of
all these days so janupomniacci seems
he's liking
to play in the evening we are waiting
for him to arrive with the white pieces
in the final game of today and a big big
advantage david to go into day two
as the winner of day one so are we
expecting some blood now
i am expecting some blood but i think in
order to get that blood napoleon will
need to try something different
to what he tried um two games ago when
he last had the white pieces
last time he went full charge into
anishigiri's
opening preparation it didn't quite work
out
he was completely neutralized and he
guided that game towards safety and we
did see a draw the polyacry maybe the
best way to be anishgary
a uh opening expert is to just surprise
him early on or take it into
slower karma waters where anishikiri
maybe hasn't had to show his skills so
far as much i was just going to ask you
the question of course
one of our prizes is the anish geary
chesapore night of course
will should well rather shoot and the
probably actually take him on
in this minefield yeah i mean it's so
tempting right
if your opponent plays the same openings
as you do to test them in that
battleground
it's your own home ground it's also
their home ground you both know so much
but um i personally i'm very biased i
never
go to my opponent's strong points i
always try to serve towards their weak
side
i always try and catch them off guard um
in the opening
that's what gary's been working on the
hardest the sicilian night off if he's
putting courses out if he's preparing
for the candidates so
um maybe the best strategy is to try and
catch them off guard okay we do see the
sicilian though we might be heading back
um towards that sicilian night or kaya
your favorite opening yes um anisha's
favorite opening is jan's favorite
opening
as well and we see a repetition of
game two so far the poisoned pawn
variation there we go black grabs that
pawn
that dictates that black is happy to
drink that poison
and anish giri he is sticking to his
guns
we saw this position earlier in game two
exactly the same
so far how will okay diana pogchi does
finally make the first deviation um the
paths have diverged from that game
he brought his bishop out to a different
square this time and ishqiri
he was ready brook drives itself across
attacking white's bishop the light
squared bishop will we see a trade of
light squared bishops here ivanka
um i mean this is deep opening theory
both of these players will have studied
this position with their coaches and
with a computer with another yeah
that's this engine yeah it was quite
interesting that you say
you know because i i suspect that napoli
actually didn't know his lines were
just judging by his reaction in game two
and uh what he's had
is he's spoken to his seconds and
seconds have gone
here's the file you have ten minutes get
going
this is the idea yeah i mean the margins
between these players at the top level
is so small that
even having 10 minutes of consultation
with some of your coaches
um it can prove to be the difference but
um this is very direct stuff we see a
set of bishops leaving the world and a
set of queensland uh and a set of
knights leaving the board sorry
um and white now is going for checkmate
napomni actually going i mean actually
if black plays a very natural move here
bishop takes bishop
is checkmate in two moves um there's a
huge threat in the position as well
okay he reacts by counter-attacking he
goes for the white king
look this is crazy stuff white king is
walking up the board wow okay no not
quite yet not quite yet
okay the bishop is coming to block the
check and uh
still there's absolutely anything to
play for
because wow we have attack we have
counter-attack unbelievable stuff i
fully expected the white queen to
retreat um david does it work
i'm i'm trying to work it out it's so
complicated this position
black is a pawn up with his last move as
well black attacked the white queen the
pontiac didn't care
he counter-attacked he's attacking the
black queen now both queens under threat
um absolute chaos right now um
jana ponnechi this was his deep idea
imagine he only gets a 10 minute break
between the games but he spent all of it
studying this line
i think black has to be very careful he
should be fine um i'm also trying to
use the hint that the players don't get
of looking at the evaluation bar
um to gauge the position and there was a
black
jettison's his queen we call that a
pseudo sacrifice where you give up your
queen temporarily
but you get the opponent's queen back
and now
we're in the end game black is a porn up
but white rook white's bishop uh
potentially as well they will be
much more active than their counterparts
look we're on move 23
both players especially in the pogba
he's almost at 18 minutes
he only started with 15. and here we go
and and the moves just keep uh
instantly playing themselves on the
board i mean absolutely unbelievable i
mean this is
seriously deep prep um the probably
actually has 18 minutes on the clock
gary has just under 17 minutes like
we've never seen like before 24 moves on
the board i think the only time we've
seen this before in the tour is uh in
the last tournament where maxine basha
de grav
had 19 and a half minutes when he
blunded and went into a losing kingdom
pawn end game
so he amassed he'd gained all that time
remember the players
having a 10 second increment after every
move but meanwhile okay
let's do a quick overview of this
position
white is down a porn remember but
white's uh
key kind of trump card here is the fact
that his rook
is so active black's rook in the corner
meanwhile
hasn't found any open lines and black
still has the right to castle
but he can't right now because the black
king is tied down to his bishop
um just while anishgiri thinks because i
expect him to think for a long time here
he can think for a long time if he wants
to um just while anishgiri thinks if we
bring up the board we can see
the main dilemma facing black um
okay yeah but uh um he just needs to
deal with his king essentially
black needs to get his king to safety
even in the end game
he also needs to activate that black
rook because otherwise despite the fact
he's a point up
he will be paralyzed he will get his
pieces dominated
so yeah are the chances for both sides
here do you think we're going to see
a long hard fighting game i mean there's
not many pieces left
and both sides have a lot of time on the
clock yeah um i think the next few moves
are critical if anish isn't accurate
then we could see him getting tortured
for a long time
napoli actually will start amping up the
pressure and it's not going to be easy
for gerry but if
gary is accurate he should i think there
are maybe two or three ways to
um kind of release the pressure shall we
have a look at the best way
yep if we can bring up the board this
time um we can see that
black currently does have one passive
rook
this rook needs open lines we did see it
as well black pushed this pawn in order
to try and activate the rook
but it was completely blocked off white
for refusing to open up lines therefore
this rook
needs squares you cannot castle the king
remember because your bishop would drop
off
in the middle of the board and i think
the only other way to activate the rook
or the best way at least
is to maybe push this pawn forward give
back your extra pawn
sometimes that's the best thing to do
when you're under pressure you have an
extra pawn for a reason give it back
in order to open up lines and now the
rook finally has somewhere to jump to it
will capture this pawn
then next the other pawn will drop and
black is
right back in the game i think this is
the key move for any giri um pushing
this pawn forward it's not the only move
you could for example play a really long
maneuver you could
move your rook forward one square then
you can move these two pawns out the way
but that to me just looks way too
inhuman too slow
um kind of counterproductive unless
there's an immediate gain and yeah this
one to me
looks correct i really like that move
actually it's funnily enough
for someone who likes pushing pawns
didn't even occur to me to push the pawn
two squares i was thinking about pushing
it one square
and then tucking the king with the same
idea but uh this one looks absolutely
brilliant because it also disrupts uh
the white pawn structure there on the
right side of the board
and i really like what uh david has
suggested
will it happen what do you think uh it's
not clear whether that will happen it's
maybe not the most obvious move it's not
human instinct to give back upon
um on an empty square unless you have
immediate gains but here there are an
immediate well i mean there is an
immediate reason
for that move so gary he's doing the
right thing as soon as you reach a
position that's new to you
after the opening just take a pause and
uh
reassess start calculating um
promises body language he looks a bit
bored he's probably studied this
position in that 10 minute break
and that's i mean that's just amazing to
me
um but and uh well as any she is
thinking in this very critical position
we are joined by magnus carlsen after a
very good day against wesley so magnus
how happy are you with your play today
i was okay um you don't need that
that first game no but the the thing is
that uh um
this knight of six is uh something that
uh
um that wasn't wasn't a file peter sent
me earlier today
so uh obviously if if it had been
my idea that i found found over the
board i would be
would be very proud um obviously i
didn't know
um the whole the whole line after
after what happened um
so magnus i had to
i had to figure out some of that over
the world
um but truth be told it wasn't
wasn't very uh wasn't very difficult
after after f5
uh but still i mean it's it's a great
feeling obviously to
to be such a good player in in that sort
of style
and yeah i know we have the the the
first game here
on your an analysis of word david um
this was simply spectacular yeah i have
to ask magnus you said this was in your
file this was in your opening
preparation but
personally i've never seen this move on
move four before is this
have you revolutionized chess openings
with this move
no it's been played i think like by
fun forest i believe and some some
others
um what's the idea behind it it looks so
counterproductive or counterintuitive at
least
you grab some space
[Laughter]
sounds so simple yeah
the thing is you're trying to get a good
version of something
um some opening in in reverse
like after after d5 you're claiming that
a4 is a
is a useful move there um
and also after moves like bishop c5 or
bishop b4
rubbish b7 whatever you're trying
trying again to claim that that
that there is use for the movie for uh
realistically obviously it's not even
close to being better um
but uh yeah the fact that i actually
managed to
um to play he sort of jumped into the
one
line where white has a serious ideas
obviously pretty fortunate for me but
um still very very satisfying
so magnus did you simply have fun
playing today without maybe too much
pressure
no i would say i wasn't particularly
motivated for it before
today but the first game helped
immensely
after that i sort of
tried to treat it as as a series match
and that i
i wanted to um
i i wanted at least not to score any
own goals like i did on the on the
previous day two days
now uh we are following the final game
with uh
nepo and denise can we get your
expert verdict on this strange
position with very few pieces left
uh i think it's pretty much an ideal
situation
for for yan here he's way up on
way up in time the scoring the match is
it's equal and
it feels it feels like he has a little
bit of
a pressure at least psychologically
speaking so
i think he he must be pretty pretty
happy
i'm sure the computer spits out
spits out the draw and one or
probably many ways but yeah it's it's a
lot more pleasant to
to be on here so yeah you i mean i i
agree i would prefer yan's position here
but
if you were a niche on the flip side um
if you had less time and
maybe some passive pieces how would you
approach this position with black
i would try and force matters um
[Music]
probably that's that's what i would say
okay
he doesn't have he does he have the
right to castle by the way
yes yeah i can't
yeah i was thinking of uh of lines like
age three here and
uh
lines like h3 and uh something like
bishop g5
takes takes and if not for for castle
well there's also rook f8 actually uh
but castle obviously solves all the
other problems you can have
castling so late in the game yeah this
is a strange game this is a strange day
i hope you enjoyed it magnus we
certainly did following your games
no as i said the first game helped
immensely when it came to
to to motivation and um
i mean the other the other match has
been has been fun to
to follow uh follow as well all right we
thank you so much for joining us minus
good luck tomorrow as well
thank you i actually i saw on norwegian
tv too they named that game the first
game murder on
a chessboard so do we actually have like
we
with the the opera game and the game of
the century
do we have another one here for history
books yeah i think so
i mean not only is that a rare opening
idea that's only been seen before a few
times but
just the manner in which it happened i
mean just brutal it's very rare to see
such a one-sided game among
uh i mean between two world-class
players yeah um i mean
i know this tournament's named after him
but this game should be named after
magnus as well yeah i think
yeah now i just do have to show you this
picture because you were talking about
names and uh morton freeman
showed a picture quite cool picture says
who's this stormtrooper
playing and you can see it's the
pontiac's empty chair
so uh perhaps this could be nicknamed
the stormtrooper
or you know it's quite fitting after all
because
napoli actually has been quoting a lot
of yoda
that's true that's true and he is uh
looking very
zen yeah where he's sitting right now i
mean with 17 minutes on the clock no
problem well he did say you know there
can only be one
apprentice one master and uh he's making
it clear
he is the master yeah i think that
quote's from the phantom menace so
he's playing like a bit of a menace in
this game he's trying to
threaten uh i know that was crafty like
is he saying that that niche was the
phantom menace
like was there another level to the
tweet that we these guys they love their
other levels
yeah meanwhile anish has been under
pressure has been spending a long time
on the clock
10 minutes down now but i think he's
come up with a good move
um if we bring up the analysis board we
can see magnus carson
was going uh for a very well was
advocating a very direct
forcing path towards a draw he mentioned
that that was anish's best bet
and anish he's trying that it doesn't
look like it at first his last move
pushing this pawn
but the reason this pawn has been pushed
is because now this pawn controls a key
square
it controls this square so if white
tries to start picking off pawns on the
other flank
on the other side of the board then
suddenly anishigiri his rook will
finally get active uh and it will start
munching on pawn so we do see a check
in this position will anish giri just
step forward with his king i expect to
see this move
if the rooks disappear from the board
this game should just be a simple draw
black's still a pawn up but one of these
pawns eventually will drop and the game
will just fizzle out
and um yeah if not nopony actually wants
to win i think in the current position
he cannot trade rooks he has to find
another square um
he has to maybe drop the rook back um
eyeing up two
other pawns let's see janupolici's
decision
um a lot of time on the clock it should
be a draw with best play but
the key thing is white is on the attack
so he can still try and dictate things
try and set some traps um for anish to
fall into
anish not out of the woods yet but
defending well so far yes certainly and
uh the rook move that you predicted
david is on the board
and of course napomireti has to make a
choice and there you see it
instantly moving his rook to an open
diagonal
so uh now we have the choice of pawns
which pawn would you take
i think i would uh i have to say ivanka
rook to an open diagonal that's a new
one for me did i say i wrote an open
diagonal
[Laughter]
i like it
[Laughter]
up all the time yeah rick turned open
line
that's fantastic ivanka played chess her
whole life talking about bishops and
rooks
her whole life and then suddenly the
rook goes on diagonals i know
i'll forgive you because the bishops do
kind of play a big part of this position
exactly i was thinking that i was
thinking ahead this is my mistake i was
thinking which
which pawn would you take and i was
primarily considering bishop takes porn
so uh that's where the diagonal came
across
mason center um yeah i think if we bring
up the analysis board we have to
commend anish giri on his last move uh
white dropping the rook back
attacking two pawns now attacking this
pawn with his bishop and
attacking this corner pawn and nishikuri
doesn't go on the defensive and
this is something for everyone to
remember whether you're beginning the
game
or whether you're an expert level um
just sometimes it's better to go active
than to go passive with your pieces so
just ignore the pawns it's better to
activate the black rook
black's rook bring itself across to this
open diagonal
and the black rook is simply going to
target white's pawns no matter which
pawn white takes
the black rook okay it could jump into
this position eyeing up these two guys
or maybe even stronger it's going to pin
this white bishop against the king so
activate your pieces everyone should do
this that's the best way to defend
difficult end games and uh ding ding
ding ding ding after
having played for 15 minutes and 30
moves jana pogba is now
under the time that he started with yeah
about time yeah um that's why they call
him the speed demon and
oh yeah yeah okay well he has taken the
pawn
and now we're fully expecting a niche to
come in
and i really like the move that you
suggested just pinning
the bishop and the king together i mean
just love that one
i think it's the most natural move on
the board because it just poses some
kind of
problems for for white what are you
going to do step back yep i agree
um why not create a threat simon
williams said it if you don't have any
uh kind of decisive checks don't have
decisive captures
create a threat there we go anish giri
creates a threat he creates that pin
he was striking to drop a porn down and
attack white's bishop he would have won
white's bishop that's why
the white king had to step out of the
line of fire um
and there we go black's pawns have
started advancing um
look how much more active anishiri's
position is now than it was just three
or four moves ago
white's bishop takes a pawn so okay the
pogiacci who was a pawn down just two
three moves ago is now a pawn up
but the problem is it is a rook end game
rookie games have george tendencies and
once the bishops disappear from the
board
i think anishigiri will just capture
that bishop once that happens
white's remaining pawns they're all
isolated and it won't be possible to
save
all of them yeah well this is the big
question is anish gonna
gonna try for more or is he simply gonna
just liquidate the position
just advance a few pawns and just let
everything simplify
agree draw no that's a good point ivanka
i didn't even see that anishigiri could
play for the win here
and maybe he can um if anish giri is
feeling ambitious he will not trade the
bishops yet
he will play pawn down and give check to
the white king
um maybe that's the more ambitious move
um
it won't change the evaluation too much
i think but maybe ill force no problem
actually to be the one
finding some accurate replies in return
and that's the key here
everything should lead to a draw but
maybe you can force your opponent to
um i mean find a narrow path that's the
key in any chess game
um give them the kind of give them the
opportunity to make a mistake at least
and uh we have talked about these two
players being the
like the best chess players in form
right now in
shape before the candidates and uh they
don't make any blunders so
is it going to be hard yeah without
those blunders to be able to find a win
here
yeah i mean this uh i mean rapid games
with only 15 minutes on the clock
they're full of blunders we've seen it
before but
this final it's been error free pretty
much yeah i can't remember a single
mistake i mean small inaccuracies but
that's always going to happen
but not no big mistakes from either side
yeah i mean the closest that i would say
came in game one when anish was actually
totally winning and he just let the wind
slip
but it was nothing like oh my god what a
terrible move it was kind of more like a
gradual series of inaccuracies
and well i think anish is going to end
the day in some
peaceful mood i think the pawns are
going to get swapped off and we're going
to see
a very theoretical technical uh rick and
porn engine which is just completely
drawn
yup so black has options now he could
push his own pawns
black's rook as well it could drop down
two squares and attack two white pawns
at the same time
that would pretty much guarantee a draw
um you see on the pontiac's face he
yeah he knows that he tested anishkuri
he had this long
opening preparation okay there we see
the double attack on white spawns
but yeah the probably actually he tried
something it nearly worked but
anishikari had all the answers and
sometimes that's all you can do um go
for the draw and here we're seeing all
of the pawns start to disappear
um we might even see okay we're gonna
see king versus king i'm gonna
yeah okay there we go and everything
everything traded off everything
hoovered off the board wow
uh we do definitely we definitely have a
draw in the final game
uh between anish geary and diana
pognyard cheats
four games four draws in the final so
far
it is intense it is such a close race it
is two
fantastic players in great shape and
they're not
letting each other in on in any way
like uh they're just completely uh
rock solid both of them yeah totally
rock solid especially in those last
three games
the funny thing is they have been
playing wild
openings in a totally unexpected and
you would they certainly think that from
that opening that you would get
something crazy crazy
and it was for time being but suddenly
they navigated the waters and before you
know it
position is a draw and it's been perfect
chance yeah and this was certainly a
well a strange game david uh with very
few pieces after only a few moves and uh
they didn't spend a lot of time either
yeah they didn't spend a lot of time and
that is because janna palmer
niacci especially he was very well
prepared he tested anishigiri and
actually david i'm just going to jump in
because i actually think we have iana
ponnyacci joining us and then it would
be so much fun to have both
jan and david uh go through this uh
final game for us if that's okay um
yes uh so good evening what do you want
me to explain
david you take it away yeah i guess this
last opening that we saw uh
twice in the games today i mean oh sorry
yeah but uh you
first in in the first game you played
this move the second game you played
this
uh this special movie did you have a
chat with maybe a friend a second
um in the beginning yes yeah i mean
obviously so
i studied this line like i guess half a
year ago
for i guess for both colors and yeah
it's
just the draw to my taste it's a little
bit passive yeah the same game but
once you know the moves like h5 is 4f5
and okay all these move over there which
showed uh this this is just a draw yeah
so i mean if you
slow down here and play inaccurately
then okay perhaps black could be in
trouble
in a slight one button no i mean okay
white is trying well let's say
but uh indeed was obviously finished is
very well prepared so this
i mean okay people normally think that
neither is much like uh
you know he's very very fighting but
this one is much like berlin yeah so
we we surely missed queen before queenie
for you
why are we playing such a game hard to
break down for sure
well um jan i have to say it's been a
flawless day for you you played
completely rock solid
given no chances to a niche so are you
happy about the day
uh well first of all i guess i wish i
had a massive chance in game one
so and he was somewhat better maybe not
that much but somewhat better for sure
in game three
so i wouldn't say it was anything like
solid yet perhaps be white
but yes i guess yesterday
took a little bit more energy from me
you know than from a niche yeah so i
guess he's
today he was sort of more french but any
day this is like
to to the image and uh okay tomorrow it
it's uh it's gonna be decided so well
i'm morally satisfied that okay i
uh you know i had you know some
concerns about uh how
how will i play after yesterday's
massacre
you call it a massacre okay well you
because you have been a little bit
critical young of
sort of the intensity of the tournament
so many games so many
long days it must be exhausting for you
guys
uh to play and then heading into the
finals so are you
sort of happy with your performance
today uh
well i didn't lose any games so
that that's why yes and especially
what makes me happy is that tomorrow is
the last day of the tournament and then
finally i can switch to preparation
yeah i think so you know yeah it's
of course it's a big fun to play here
and since i made it to the finals i mean
it's
also like uh very
okay i i guess i could be proud of
myself but uh
anyway okay you you know my goals are
slightly different
and okay they're not only but not about
this tournament only
and yep it's yeah it's been
it's been a long run so what can you do
tomorrow then to get that
one win i mean if a niche doesn't win
anyone any games what can you do to win
that one game to
to win the tournament overall well
probably i gotta
study some more night or yeah we have it
let's find some improvement to move 45
here
yeah i know have you uh been taking a
peek at
uh anisha's chestable course on the
night off
well actually i guess i
don't you know i don't earn that
to pay much a crazy amount for the
course here but
it could be could be a good idea but i
guess uh anyway i won't have enough time
to study
the whole course uh until tomorrow so
good idea to rest as well john good luck
tomorrow on the final day thanks for
joining us
thank you uh and i think we're also
joined by anishkiri geary can you
hear me yeah i can hear you all right
have you believed
it yeah i have heard many trash talks
but you know hitting it where it hurts
into my neighbor of course and calling
it expensive
i mean it's just it's just it's below
the belt i mean i've seen different
things but this is just below the belt
it's completely unacceptable
and i i think and he realizes that and
tomorrow i'll be furious this is not
acceptable oh okay i mean
at the discount you know the material i
mean it's like i don't know like 30
or something like this yeah well you
have to know like how much
knowledge and time and effort was put
into it
and to call it expensive i mean it's
just um yeah
i just have no words simply for this
well we have enjoyed the najdorf today
anish four draws
uh we were talking about you i mean
neither of you make any mistakes you're
you're
rock solid so how do you feel about your
performance today
well when i played black i was very
solid last game to be honest
i was prepared really far
like all the way into the rook bishop
end game including the
h3o5 it's very important to the whole
line because
sometimes you know it's a base um yeah
basically
it's all based on this kind of nuances
in the endgame sometimes and
this is one line that i don't give in my
course because i find it
too unrealistic for uh amateurs or club
players i mean this will never happen
right in their games but in top level
chess
it can happen that everybody knows all
the way to the end in rare cases so
yeah that was that was solid the other
black game was also pretty solid but in
the white games i think they were
that was excitement especially the first
one i was a bit
slow though at some point i thought i
will win anyway because it's
but it was never 100 easy like he always
had
some sort of um some chances of survival
going and
then when i traded a lot of things even
there still
yeah like it's not so easy he's got a
past one so
i didn't have any time and i it was not
uh
an open goal but i definitely had to
score that one for sure
and yeah as you mentioned anish um super
solid with black
not showing any chinks in your armor and
uh with white maybe a couple of small
missed opportunities what will you
be doing differently um tomorrow with
white to maybe take those challenges
when they come
i mean niger is like this russian
roulette yeah i mean
i'm gonna be taking four bullets but
there is one there with the
you know there is one with one one with
the bullet basically so one shot so
yeah it's uh it's it's a russian
roulette this night or if it's not
exactly solid
uh but we'll see we'll see i've also got
the berlin if push comes to shove
and um yeah even in the white games i
mean he's such a
ambitious and uh quick and uh
reckless player that you get and you
like end up giving chances with white
with black
even sometimes when you don't expect it
even when you are winning you can lose
or the way around like
it's like a little bit of a mayhem
against him i guess jan so i
uh i don't really have like you know
like a long-term plan like draw with
black wind with white
i don't think that's the case uh i think
you can win or lose either color and
yes i've played him a lot of times it's
always complete coin toss
and he does obviously he shows weakness
of course i mean if you only look at his
strengths you think that this is the
best player out there
he is faster more dangerous
sharper than magnus you know more
tactically alert
there's much more aggression coming from
him so uh if you know if you look only
at his process you think he's the best
player in the world but
you know the other participants also
compete so that that means that he also
has some vulnerabilities and you see
that sometimes he makes quick
judgments sometimes he's unprepared a
little bit
it's possible uh but we'll see we'll see
what happens only four games to go and
it's gonna be very exciting
and uh well finally in each either way
tomorrow we're gonna find a winner one
game
at some point we'll end up with the
winner so how will the nurse be for you
tomorrow
the nurse will be fine but like the one
thing i can agree with uh with jan is
that
uh yeah definitely a relief that
tomorrow is the
final uh final day because uh my
you know i'm unable to check up on my
team what they are doing i have
suspicion they're they're
lying on sofas you know at the cost of
that chess federation
uh watching our games with popcorn and
coke
occasionally they send me some files but
i'm really not sure um
you know they could be just working two
hours out of the whole day and i have no
proof
i have to really get back to the to the
training camp check up on my voice and
make sure
everything's running smoothly because we
gotta prepare for the candidates all
right well
uh we hope you have some fun on the
final day tomorrow first before you
check on your voice
thanks for joining niche good luck
tomorrow
all right well good mood on the players
yes certainly some good mood from
anish there i really did like his sense
of humor when he said he needs to get
back and
check up on his team you know slave
drive all right
and uh yeah no i also liked the
napoleonic it was nice to see him in a
good mood yep
definitely the two finalists they are in
a good mood nothing decided yet let's
take a look at the results after the
first
match in the finals they played four
draws it hasn't been boring it's been
interesting and fantastic chess by two
fantastic chess players in form
four draw so they are tied after today
magnus carlsen was the winner of the
first match in the battle for
third place with a fantastic win
especially in that first game
against wesley so and we are talking
about
fantastic chess games today ivanka yeah
we are talking about the fantastic chess
games and certainly the ones that we've
seen the ones that we like the best
and that is the question of the day what
is your favorite chess game and the
lucky winner
wow it's an unbelievable prize we know
it now
one year's chess pretend chess 24
premium membership
uh anish geary's a sicilian idol
chessable course one year chessboard pro
membership
and if that's not enough one year magnus
trainer membership
and uh yep here before we announce the
lucky winner of that magnificent prize
brought to you by opera well we're going
to show
some tweets that we especially liked
abraham kahel
it says mikhail natal's knight six
sacrifices for almost no
immediate returns to fully activate his
forces and refuse to
retreat and there you can see a picture
of tao with pod vinnick
and we also liked michael landino
13 year old magnus vs kasparov aside
from the impressive game the
psychological aspects of the game are
second to none and then finally gunther
blauvens we really like this one
my favorite chess game was against my
grandson
jack is so cute yeah he usually opens
french before and sicilian after his
afternoon
now i should never have let him start
with whites
but the lucky winner of our prize today
well that goes to
emin who says his favorite chess game
definitely
rajabov against kasparov which ended
with raja's victory
the night sacrificed by taymor was
brilliant even kasparov missed that move
beating kasparov when he was dominating
chess world just
unbelievable wow and uh yeah rajapov was
only 16 years old at the time so it's
absolutely magnificent game
and has later been a winner in the
meltdown to champions chester he won the
first major
tomorrow we'll decide who wins the
second one so david who's your favorite
ah so hard to pick a favorite they've
both been in great form throughout the
tournament
and also today i'm gonna pick anish giri
he was on the front foot for most of
those games especially with white two
missed chances
if you can just take one chance tomorrow
it should guide him to victory do you
think we'll see some of the same ivanka
for very you know just not
none of them sort of daring to take very
big risks or
will we see something different tomorrow
i think we're going to see more of the
same you know an
explosive opening where there will be a
lot of action
from the start and i think we might see
a few lucky escapes again
and we're going to see blood on the
board that's for sure all right you
micah said it blood on the board
tomorrow is the final day
of the magnus crossing invitational we
will find out if aneesh giri or
jana pomnyacci is the winner of the
second major
in the mouthwater champions chess tour
so we are looking forward to a
dramatic intense a fun day of chess we
hope you will be back to join us we
definitely
will be back with the huge excitement so
see you tomorrow
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
you